Three,
two,
one.
Well,
live.
Well live.
What's up brother?
What's up dude?
How are you Betty?
Good.
We got you in here finally,
man.
How many times do we have to talk about this?
Several,
right?
This was,
the universe wanted it.
The universe made it happen after the till.
Victory.
There was a,
that was,
that was a,
for a lot of people,
a big coming out party for you.
Why is it?
Yeah,
you were already out,
but that was like,
Holy Shit.
The way you put him out,
it was Whoa,
that was a holy shit moment.
I was going for that moment.
That's what I was trying to do.
Yeah.
And you had decision wasn't going to come my way that way.
You know,
I not to say nothing about,
uh,
the English,
but I,
I don't like the judging over there.
I've seen a lot of decisions go like crooked.
I don't like decisions in almost every state.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean there's,
there's decisions in almost every athletic commission that you just shake your
head out and you don't understand.
What's the worst thing you can think of?
I don't know.
I don't know,
I'd have to sit back and go over the archives,
but I've seen some horrible ones.
Even ones where guys,
when they like barely when you're like,
how the fuck was that close?
Like 29 that kind of shit.
And you're like,
what are the town?
Yeah,
there's a lot of those.
And it's getting better though.
Cause more fighters every are joining that force,
you know?
I see.
Or I hear about fighters they used to fight that are involved in the commissions
at least second Florida and stuff.
So I know 10 years from now is going to be nothing but productive people in the
people that know what they're looking at.
You know,
we can only hope that,
I mean that's the number one problem.
I think that scoring system sucks to like adopting a ten nine even the new
improved scoring systems like MMA is so much different than boxing and to adopt
this scoring system just because it already existed for boxing,
you know,
that's like adopting the rules of tennis for Ping Pong.
Like the different things.
This is a mafia,
is that what is the boxing thing?
Huh?
Yeah.
Why is a boxing commission governing the MMA commission?
Shouldn't we have our own thing?
Yeah.
I think in some places they just didn't have the infrastructure,
you know?
And nowadays we could do it nowadays for sure.
Yeah.
In most places.
But yeah,
it's um,
mean time to change.
I mean,
you been around for a long time.
My friend,
I remember the first time I ever saw you fight.
It was a,
a backyard,
bare knuckle fight in the Kimbo slice days.
That was the first time I heard about you.
And then I saw you fight Eve Edwards and Bodog.
Oh,
dog fight.
Yeah.
It was a golden age.
The golden age is Matt's a while ago.
Damn.
It's crazy.
Like Bodog fight was fun.
Organization change.
Alaska has fought there.
Chill son and fought there.
Eddie average.
That's right.
Yeah.
Fade or fade or had a fight over there.
Afraid I had a fight over there.
Brad Pickett as well.
Yeah.
I'm Mike Brown.
But what happened with them?
They went under because of the,
the whole gambling rules online changed right off from what I heard.
If no one I heard was a spending budget,
I,
well this is what I,
what I heard,
um,
Calvin air,
there was the owner of both,
right?
He
put up this huge budget and these are just rumors from what I heard from the
people working,
you know,
but it was like $100 million for Xyz and mine.
I used to get them publicity so people would see the fights and then go to the
casino.
That 100 million got blown out like in two,
three years is what I heard.
Ah,
and I wouldn't disagree cause they used to pay me really good and give us super
perks.
They usually give us some super perks,
you know,
take us to exotic locations to fight,
be there for two weeks,
you plus two that flout take care of you.
They really,
really took very good care of me.
So when I heard that they blow out 100 million in three years,
I was like,
yeah,
it could be,
you know.
Well they were fighting on the beach with hot girls in bikinis and wandered
around dancing.
But you were on the beach like in the sun.
I was like,
what the fuck is fucking ideas and to fight in the sun.
But let me tell you the training sessions that went on,
there were some of the best that I've seen the world cause they,
so you would go and you'd bring two of your corner man.
And then somebody found that and then before you know you had like four people,
if your entourage going with you from whatever team that was.
And everybody was doing that and we'd have a training place in what they had
done was laid out tarps and mats and it was huge.
So we'd have like a hundred proles 50 pros from all over the world,
just training,
you know,
and when you to know each other and it's like,
hey,
you want to roll?
You know,
it gets competitive,
you know.
So there was some great training sessions that I saw and that I,
that I took a part of,
you know?
Wow.
Yeah.
It was fun,
man.
Look,
the,
the world needs more of those.
They meed more one fcs.
We need more Bella tours.
We need more,
you know,
composition,
whatever the professional fight league is called now.
What did they call themselves now?
Is that what it is?
It's Pfl used to be world series of fighting.
That's right.
Yeah.
We need more,
need more of them.
Oh,
so PFLs world series event.
He used to be world series downs.
PFL Okay.
Yeah,
I think pretty sure.
Most of the same organization.
Okay.
Yeah.
Do we need,
we need more,
you know,
I need more money.
Yeah.
That Oscar de la Hoya thing,
you know that that's probably never going to happen again after the,
the Tito and chuck fight and it doesn't just look like,
but someone of that ilk,
someone like a golden boy promotions,
they started getting involved in MMA and putting together,
they get some guys that aren't signed but are super high level with a big name.
Like maybe the contract comes up and they decided to do something with a big
name promoter.
You know,
it'd be good for everybody.
Yeah.
Golden boy tried,
uh,
many years ago,
didn't they?
With reflection was an Oscar part of that.
I remember Oscar Donald Trump.
That's right.
Yeah.
Was a part of affliction and that's right.
Josh Barnett sunk that ship.
Josh Brent had tested positive and that ship sunk,
remember?
Yeah.
And then the UFC bought it like right afterwards.
That they had some fun fights though.
That fucking Tim Silvia Fade or fight was wild as shit.
Andrea at [inaudible] art.
Look at Donald Trump.
He would Thomas
10th.
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
Back in the day.
Sun.
Yeah.
Donald Trump and Tim Sylvia.
That's hilarious.
He was a totally different character back then to our troubles.
Like a fun guy.
Like everybody liked him.
People liked him.
He'd get cheered on.
Now people are so fucking mad at him.
Same Guy.
I don't see him that when it weren't.
No,
they don't.
They don't,
man.
That's why he has us security around them now.
Oh yeah.
You has to.
Yeah.
You fucked up.
Came President yet.
It's a huge mistake for anybody.
You want to enjoy your life.
Don't be fucking president as has,
you know,
he could disappear and get facial surgery or something.
Of course,
once you get that booklet with all the secrets of the history,
just for that,
the CFR book just for that,
what do you think gives you that book?
Is it a,
the CIA,
the NSA or who comes to you with the book?
Some guy with no face.
Nothing.
No face.
Yeah,
like a,
the,
the guy with the march anyway and the mass.
What is the watchmen,
who was that guy?
Ink Blot.
What's his name?
Shack.
Raw Shack.
That's right.
That guy.
Yeah.
He comes to you and come see what the bone to be.
Everything's in that book.
We,
we all know what's in that book.
Tell me,
I don't know what's in that book.
You don't know what's in that book?
What's in the book?
You think?
I'm going to say here in Wa are people are listening to get killed.
I can't say I seen the book,
but I can't tell.
What do you think's in the bone?
Joe?
What do you think?
If you had to guess,
like he didn't even want to say President Jorge.
You're first day in office.
Mr Mosfet doll a word you like to?
Uh,
would you like to go over first?
Is Elvis still alive?
What about Tupac?
Where the fuck we're super guy.
Who else?
What's going on with these Amy's Bro,
they real witch,
which was mine,
number one.
One.
Number one I want to know about aliens.
I was hoping,
this is my hope when all these people are screaming his treats about Trump,
like,
Nah,
I was hoping the moment he gets in,
he's going to ask about aliens because Trump's into conspiracies.
Like he used to go on the Alex Jones show all the time.
I know he's in conspiracies.
If you were going to be the president,
the first thing you ask is fucking aliens.
What do you got going on here with these green fellows?
Now we talk about what's going on with them.
You live in Florida.
There's plenty of aliens down there now.
We don't go,
Oh yeah,
we've got a lot of aliens,
different types of 18 Florida's we're talking about those reps,
Florida,
the trip.
It's one of my favorite places because it literally,
especially the whole southern Florida area,
like Miami West Palm down,
it seems like you should have a passport to go there.
It's just,
it's so different than the rest of America.
It's going to speak English.
It's great.
The food is all exotic.
It's like it's,
it's,
it's such a different flavor and then the weather's crazy.
It,
which it's almost like going to another country.
Yeah,
you needed a little pat.
You go to the guys.
He's in Trump.
Put Gadget.
What language are you speaking?
Nobody speaks English there.
People get upset.
I'm always at a gas station and then somebody like an American person will be in
the line and fucking,
dammit man,
nobody speaks English here and then I'll have to like translate it.
I'll come down,
man.
It's okay bro.
There's people who speak English and Spanish,
you know it's,
yeah,
and it's also the weather there.
It's when it gets crazy,
it gets so crazy.
I went with Eddie Bravo once and he was doing a Jujitsu seminar.
We had to drive from a west palm down to Miami and as we're driving this storm
hit,
it was so hard.
You had to,
everyone stopped dead on the highway because you couldn't drive cause you
couldn't see in front of you.
We were laughing.
No one could see anything.
It was just all a wall of water that was pounding down in the car for about 10
minutes and then it all went away.
We were like,
what in the fuck was that?
You can't see in front of you.
It didn't matter if he had windshield wipers on and you are going nowhere.
You couldn't drive.
You couldn't see.
Sounds about right.
That's about right.
Right.
That's why Mami people,
Florida people got that a spastic uh,
behaviors.
We'll just like the weather.
You know where your one moment
it's all temporary.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
you being down there though,
you couldn't ask for a better training environment.
I mean with,
with Dave established down there,
I mean it was great when there was the black silicon zero as well.
But I mean,
American top team down,
they're like,
Holy Shit,
we are in Florida.
I mean black savings,
just trying to do that casing to saying that they were killing this competition.
I don't whatever happened to that team.
Well the guy died.
No,
but before that it was long extinct.
Well,
it's,
look,
Dan Lambert,
Lambert's a bad motherfucker.
It costs a lot of money to do what he did.
And T.
Dot.
Guy is a,
he's one of the treasures of the sport.
Yeah.
You know,
and what he did was not just do it once,
but then build a whole new place.
Yeah.
The giant new place with dormitories and shit.
Stay there.
Our facility and loves him.
And Dan is amazing.
Have you,
have you ever been to Dan's house?
Never have.
Oh,
he's probably going to get mad at me.
I'm going to put him on blast and number.
Fuck it.
Let's pick out on real quick.
He's rich.
So he got a really nice house to start with.
And,
uh,
you going inside the house and you don't see any pictures of his kids,
but she has a beautiful family,
but you do see pictures,
massive pictures I'm talking about.
They won't fit in this room.
They're huge pictures of his finders knocking people out of some baby people all
over his living room and you go,
wow,
I the gym is my baby.
I would know where to get rid of this.
You know,
this is,
that's his thing.
That's his baby man.
He loves him,
man.
And the hands also.
Tough motherfucker,
Bro.
I rolled with him back in the day when he was maybe like eight years ago.
He short with everybody.
And if you were world champion at night and be like,
let's roll.
Just strangers.
It's when he's pointing pretty good man.
Yeah,
he's very good.
He's a legit,
yeah,
he's a great guy too.
And I remember when that place is basically just a money hole for him.
He just kept pumping,
pumping money into it.
It was funding fighters.
Some of them took advantage of them,
a lot of them it was,
but he stuck with it.
And then he started developing world champions and now it's like,
wow,
look at that place.
I mean we talk about best gyms on the planet.
You always have to mention att,
you have to,
obviously my opinion is biased,
but I think we stand alone in the world.
I don't think,
nobody's just sheer numbers.
You know,
we just got another title holder on on my card.
We got four people from American top team finding against the world.
You know,
I think for awhile I was like Greg Jackson's an AK.
They were producing a lot of people,
but as of late,
the last like four years,
I think he's American top team.
Yeah,
down.
It's also the incredible diversity of talent that you could train with.
Yeah.
You know,
there's so many.
That's what attraction,
you're one 35 are and back home.
You're the only one 35 are and maybe you're a world class guy,
you come in here,
you got like five one 30 fibers and 30 of them might be in the top 10 in the
UFC.
You,
what do you attribute your longevity to and your enthusiasm too,
because you've always been a guy who loves fighting and you always been a guy
who mean you've had that enthusiasm for a long time.
Man.
You know,
not a lot of things,
uh,
can capture my attention,
you know,
and I,
I can't just watch TV for example,
you know,
like a football game and sit through the whole thing.
You know,
I'm not trying to digital but on that I just don't have that attention span or
basketball or baseball fighting can just like I'm talking to you in a fight goes
on and I'd just like almost get zoned out.
You know,
there's always had my attention since a kid since before I knew that I could
make money off of it.
It just attracted me,
you know,
it's that primal instinct,
survival,
whatever it is,
is just hardwired deep into Mino and my longevity.
One thing I definitely attribute to is a not taking steroids,
man.
Just being natural,
enjoying this ride,
that the natural form,
you know,
not like pushing my body towards limits that I'm bench pressing 400 pounds where
my ligaments are weak like that,
you know?
And I also think God made me for this,
you know,
the way that I've been fighting my whole career.
You know,
I have really good defense.
The last white,
it didn't show,
but I'm also like bill Hardman.
I walked out of the till,
got clipped
one left hand in the initial ft Dick kicked him,
which is crazy.
He came out as the first one I ever saw with a opening flying side kicked Dick,
kick Luke,
Hank to the balls.
Sorry.
Um,
but then he clipped you with was a perfect straight left,
but you survived on the ground.
You survived in the ground.
You covered up,
you showed great defense on the ground.
You got back to your feet and you kept it together,
you know,
and the combination that you hit him with,
you'd hit him with that combination a couple times.
You did.
Is that something you prepared for that when you were switching and then
throwing that left hand?
Is that,
did you prepare in a way?
Pet,
yeah,
me and my coach,
ah,
he's,
he's the one that'll do like all the techniques.
The guy that had been with forever Ballina and nuns,
I think the greatest dragon coach ever,
he,
ah,
he showed me like,
Hey,
let's do this.
You know,
Oh man,
I want to do a new techniques.
Come on,
let's just do it.
You know what I mean?
I started doing it,
doing it,
doing it.
And this was like a while ago and then for this fight and I had stopped doing
it,
you know,
cause a lot of the techniques we work on my lap when initiating,
when he brings me a technique to the table,
we're going to wrap it out 100 times in a week and the next week the same thing
to leave fields that I got it.
And then he'd be like,
all right,
cool.
[inaudible] they're in the tool shed when we need it.
We'll Polish it up.
So for this fight,
he's like,
Hey,
remember that technique?
Let's,
let's bring it,
I think it'll work here.
And I go,
man,
but he's just South Isaac.
I'm telling you the way he's moving the ways,
you know,
fighting with you,
it's gonna work.
So we started doing it and boom money.
You caught him with it a couple of times before you put them away with it.
Right?
I not with that one,
with that same exact one.
Similar ones,
but I didn't,
uh,
I didn't go full south Pato to the blitz,
you know,
I did it a other different ways,
and I also caught on my lap with like overhand and left hook as he was coming
in,
especially in the second round.
I caught him I think maybe twice with that come.
Yeah man,
that's a big knockout.
That was a big knockout.
He's a,
he's an interesting guy because he's really too big for one 70.
Yeah,
he's so fucking tall.
But you are a guy who doesn't cut much weight at all.
Like how much would you cut for Sec?
Well,
by the time I get into shape,
shape,
I'm around 182 pounds.
180 pounds.
So fight week,
I get over there and I'm like eight pounds away,
some seven pounds away and not so light.
Yeah,
it's nice.
I don't cut any at 55 if uh,
if everything went right when they used to fight 155 I got there at 174 pounds,
170 30 pounds,
5% body fat,
and the rest is just watermelon.
It would fucking kill me.
So I,
I always felt that was too big for 55.
You know,
I,
I loved it because the competition was stiff there,
but it was just getting harder and harder once it took those ivs away,
forget it.
There was no way for me to make that weight.
Yeah.
And moving up has been very successful for you.
I mean,
you look better moving up then I think you have ever in your career.
I don't think I had any stoppages at 55 with the hands,
like ending,
somebody had dropped a numerous people,
but I never CalEd somebody stiff,
you know.
And at seven I've got a couple of them in.
Is Do you tribute that to having more power at 70 energy hub,
healthier,
feeling confident.
You know,
once,
once you run that desert to cut the weight and then you still have to fish
fight,
that's still in the back of your mind like right.
You know,
do I have 50 good hot right hands in me,
you know?
Right,
right.
And those doubts and stuff come in you and also your insights take a beating.
When you cut that weight,
when you cut it like 12 pounds and up of water,
your insights take a beating.
So you get hit in the stomach and like,
Whoa,
that Shit fucking hurt.
It doesn't hurt like this in practice.
You know?
So,
um,
it,
it sucks man.
It sucks.
Harsh water cuts suck.
We were talking about it outside that I think that they,
if they instituted hydration tests and more weight classes and just cut it out,
just cut out,
wait,
just cut out weight,
cutting all together,
cut it out,
man.
Just,
he just figured out a way to eliminate,
make people fight it,
what they were at.
But you've got to have more weight classes.
No,
definitely.
I mean most of the population walks around between like one 45 and one 70 I
think,
man,
you know,
most of my friends are not heavy weights or,
or very short dude,
you know,
they're like right around this show.
I think definitely knows way classes.
They could definitely add more,
you know,
maybe even seven pounds in those way classes,
every seven pounds a difference.
And then as they get bigger,
they get through like 10 pounds,
you know,
like 85 95 two oh five you know,
I don't think it's,
some people said that boxing is too watered down.
I think what,
what waters down boxing is the different organization.
Yes.
I don't think it's way close.
15 bells per weight class.
Come on.
Yeah,
I don't think there's anything wrong with a one 47 and one 54 and that doesn't
me.
No,
no.
Well
that seven pounds,
47 one 54 one 60 and they have one 68 I think that's perfect.
Perfect.
Yeah.
I don't think,
I mean I think,
look,
I always thought it was weird that we didn't adopt.
If we're going to adopt the boxing 10 point must system,
why don't we adopt a weight classes?
Like why do we have our own still weirdest?
How is lightweight one 55 lightweights always in one 35 we all know that
welterweight one 47 it's not one 70 how has that welterweight like that's
ridiculous.
There was already a welter weight.
Like it's like calling a pound like,
oh well those are our pound in South Dakota.
It's seven pound,
little heavier into South Dakota.
What does that,
you know what I mean?
It's,
it's,
it would be better for the athletes,
but I get the UFC is idea that they don't want to have like all these titles.
They don't want to have like 12 different titles.
They didn't want it to be watered down,
but stone and B,
we've got a bunch of interim champions.
You're in that door.
Yeah.
Well listen,
those two that we had,
um,
this past weekend,
I don't see how anybody could argue with those more fun,
great fights.
Those are amazing.
Wow.
And uh,
I've been,
I've been training alongside the DP for a while.
She's like,
everybody knows the DPS are ready,
but this I think puts him in like a special category for sure.
That like Max and to beat him the way beat him to stun them bad and that first
round and then just every time he connected he was rocking him.
I mean he just,
he really showed his power shield the difference between a 5,545 or,
and uh,
it just showed the how can crack crack for a while.
I've seen him layout dude stiff in the gym a lot.
You know,
he's got one of the higher body counts for lean dude's us not even joking.
I believe it,
Eh,
he's got power.
Another guy who would lay dude stiff on the constant was hectic man.
Those guys got body counts for the Lombard.
Yeah,
I can imagine.
He kind of sparked hard.
Yeah.
He's as far as his little heart.
He's a wild man.
He's also a freak athlete too.
You know.
I remember when Hector was laying people out in tour before he came over to the
UFC.
I mean,
I think he fought his prime fights over there.
Really is.
That was at 85 to,
yeah,
yeah.
70 was a harsh cook for him.
Brutal cut.
He's so thick.
You know those fucking Cuban genetics,
man.
Yeah.
That's what he looks like.
Thickness oil.
Another got all nick.
She allows ridiculous 42 years old.
Even believe this is a real human when every ways,
and I'm like,
what the fuck is this?
He said,
just specimen.
You know what I mean?
Every dude,
bro.
I've been training along that guy too long.
He does.
He's one of the freaker athletes.
Oh yeah,
him Lombard.
And to me,
one of the best athletes I've ever seen that had been around with,
not too many people know him,
but he's,
he's a wild man.
Like the wildest of the button.
He,
he's the one that when he comes in the mat in the room,
me,
Joelle,
heck to every,
whoever's there that knows him takes you off the hat and goes,
guys,
here the man is years Alexis villa.
But that guy's a freak athlete,
Bro.
Two time a world champion wrestler,
Olympic bronze medalist.
But man,
they guy could play any sport,
man like ham ball.
When's he,
how long has he been over at att?
No,
no,
he's right now.
He's uh,
he's beating a sentence right now.
He's a,
he's doing a little bit of jail time for,
for a crime that he didn't commit,
but he was fine.
He find a better too.
He beat,
AH,
Joe Warren knocked him out.
Oh no shit.
Alexis villa and a man from pure athleticism and this guy would do crazy stuff,
you know,
play basketball with like a basketball high school team just by like what the
fuck was,
he was at one 25 and one 35 freak athlete or some crazy stuff.
Jabra free.
Gathy man.
Yeah,
there's some freak athletes in the sport now.
It's interesting to see the difference between the athletes from like 93,
you know,
or the first UFC he's to now,
it's a crazy difference.
I still don't think that we get the same caliber of athletes as the NFL or the
NHL or rather NBA well,
in different ways because we get the,
the best and fastest guys from like one 17 down.
Like those 45,
35 pounders,
they're growing up either wrestling or boxing or doing something of that nature.
They know they're not going to play basketball and football.
That's true.
Yeah,
that's true.
Yeah.
We do have some pretty freaky lighter-weight athletes.
How would you sit judo?
How old are you now?
34.
How many more years he,
Phil,
you're going to be doing this uh,
comfortably.
I'm gonna fight till I'm 38.
At least four more years.
And then if the money is right,
I'll stick around,
you know,
but at 38,
I've,
uh,
I would live this rollercoaster long enough.
It's time to stop,
just dedication sometime until my 2018 pro.
Wow.
Had a couple of amateur fights when pro and,
and enjoy the Schroeder cultures.
My favorite roller coaster to what training did you have before you went pro?
Um,
just that fucking somebody that had like maybe one or two pro fights in MMA,
like advising,
you're like,
Hey,
I think you should be doing this man when we go chop trees and shit.
All right,
let's go do it.
And you know,
[inaudible] fight training had fight training but it wasn't like structured,
you know,
um,
a lot of was that first original martial art.
Uh,
like as a kid,
my,
My,
uh,
dad had segment again,
anything,
you know,
martial arts because I was a very hyperactive individual,
something like that.
It's like,
man,
I've got to stick this guy in something,
you know.
So they had me like in karate.
Um,
what else?
I though maybe some taekwondo,
what I didn't get like far and a lot of these things,
cause I'd start to excel in the programs obviously because of my natural
aggressiveness.
But then in school,
if I get in trouble with the grades or anything,
my mom be like,
no,
we've got to take him out.
It's only going to further the damage.
We're not going to let them go there and be at peace.
We're going to take him out every time he messes up at school.
So I had started doing good at a gym like two,
three months and then get taken out,
you know?
So I was like a recruiting thing till I got to like 14 years old and I was like,
that's him ma'am.
I need to be in the gym all day long,
Sony Way to do it.
So when did you,
when you had parts in your career where you took it more seriously?
Oh,
well as a,
as a kid,
until I got to like 1314 I wasn't able to like Mama,
I'm not going to school to them.
I'm going to the gym now,
you know,
we'll write around.
I got 14 I knew already more or less what I wanted to do.
I had already seen the UFC enough and before the UFC came out,
I was like,
I'm either going to box or I'm gonna Wrestle.
Those two things are amazing.
The coolest things I've ever seen.
And then a UFC comes out and blows my fucking mind.
I was like,
what the fuck is this?
You're getting paid for this.
And then I was hearing what they were getting paid at them.
I was like,
man,
I could,
I could make a living off this.
I'm doing this,
fuck that.
You know,
and I invested everything I had ever since,
you know,
into this.
Wow.
So will you keep saying the resurrection is a big thing that you're putting on a
social media,
the resurrection,
resurrection.
What is that about?
Um,
no,
numerous things,
you know,
uh,
more on the personal side,
just cutting off a lot of bullshit out of my life,
like tremendous amounts of it,
you know,
um,
and focusing on what I gotta do,
you know,
done a lot of stupid shit in my career,
just from being,
from having genetics and being blessed and like,
man,
I could party all night long.
Then Park the car at the gym at 6:00 AM in the morning,
I'll wake up at 10:00 AM and then kick everybody's ass in the workout room.
And I'm not talking Shakas anybody works out women until you everyday that I'm
in there,
I'm a nightmare,
you know?
And then I go home to sleep a couple hours and go back to the gym at night and
do stupid shit like that.
And I did that for a while and I've,
not that I was currently doing that,
but I did that align with my body.
Your body has to really recover from that and to like a million other dumb
things.
So I've just focus on just fighting them,
just doing this a hundred percent and even cut out social media.
Yeah.
That I've,
I've caught a a long time ago.
But uh,
you Morna,
you know,
it's,
for me,
I'm not good with technology to start with is I'm not the greatest with
technology gives Moen stuff,
man.
You know,
you've got the Elon Musk's of this world and you got me on the other spectrum.
I just want to fight.
I just want to do athletic things.
Sports him would call me up if you're going to go for a fucking five hour
height,
but if I've got to send emails and Shit,
I'm fucked.
So when we're talking about social media,
I don't know how many followers I got and there's a lot of pressure to keep up
with the stuff,
you know?
But he still list the talking.
Yeah.
I don't ignore it.
I,
I get on it.
No managers stayed on top of me and he helps me out tremendously.
But,
uh,
I was in the special classes in elementary,
you know,
I had the short bus,
two teachers in my class,
eight students,
you know,
so you can't force me on the social niggas.
It was like I'm back in school.
But you obviously are a smart dude.
You're a smart dude.
I could tell that from talking to you.
And you're clearly smart from the way you fight,
you know,
there's no way you could fight the way you fight,
be as creative as you are and not being intelligent.
It's just you're expressing it in a different way.
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
For fighting.
You had definitely had to be smart is no,
unless you're just some crazy freak athlete.
Yeah.
I don't know.
For fighting.
Yeah.
I uh,
I definitely got like a good sense of what's good and what's bad.
Yeah.
Yeah,
definitely.
You always had that sense of,
of what's good and what's gap in terms of like if you always had good timing for
sparring.
Oh,
for,
for a straight the my most gifted ability that God said it here is boxing.
Since the first day I walked into the boxing ring,
maybe like three weeks later was the first time I will let the Scotch Bar,
you know,
and they put me to spar.
And I remember there was a couple of coaches that didn't know me.
They were handling already that the boxing team for that program.
And uh,
I used to go to this state sponsored program,
which was like $40 for the whole year.
You had access to the gym three,
four hours a day.
And it was like perfect.
You know,
it was the best thing that could happen to me.
So it was a lot of good talent.
And then we had a couple of national championships come out of the program.
And I remember my first sparring session,
sparring,
the coach is coming up to me,
he goes,
hey man,
how many amateur fights you got to go?
No,
I have never fought in my life.
What?
I come over here man and started working with you.
And it was like immediate,
you know?
And I just had like all natural born radar where I could see the punches in slow
motion.
You know,
I didn't know at the time how to react to them.
Right.
You know,
just trying to get out of the way and it would just work,
you know?
And still to this day I have that same radar so I'm,
that's just a blessing God gave me.
And also from the as well is my mother.
You should give me,
cause when the belt would come with a metal buckle and the shoes that,
that's the first test of the reflexes.
You know,
when I get home like at a tool in the morning,
I was like 1213 years old.
My mom be waiting for me.
Dodger Bruin time.
You've obviously put more work into though.
Oh yeah.
It's not just a,
this whole resurrection is,
he seemed more focused.
Definitely more focused.
I've always been like ultra focused when I got to fight,
you know,
like if nothing for forever and all my career,
like I got to fight,
that's all I'm going to make it to every single practice.
It's on my schedule.
If I got two practices today and three tomorrow and whatever it is,
I'm always going to do it outside of fighting on like once.
I don't have a fight though.
Seven,
eight weeks madness would happen.
Fucking stupid shit,
you know?
So you know,
that gets you into trouble.
That gets you out of shape and fucking I love to eat.
You know,
it's another fucking huge problem.
Right?
Yeah.
I don't have the too much.
Maybe what's the heaviest you've ever gotten in between fights was recently.
Um,
right before I went on this reality show,
I checked my weight.
I was at a staggering two.
Sexy,
no,
it was just,
it was time to cut the weight,
man.
It was just too much,
Well,
reality show is us.
I went on a,
my manager a bomb and got me this,
uh,
this deal.
We were having trouble.
This was after the Thompson five.
We couldn't really get a match up,
couldn't get a fight that I want it.
I to like a tough fine.
They were kind of off of me and I ultimate fighters and things like that.
And no disrespect to them.
I just didn't at that stage in my career,
I want the hardest fight or the best fighter that I could get.
And he's like,
calls me up when they say,
Hey,
I got this reality show.
And I was like,
oh awesome,
click
and causing me back the next day.
You work.
Don't hang up yet.
Listen to me,
you know,
um,
I think you might like,
this is not like that.
So then like Jersey shore,
it's like a competitive,
like you're going to compete against people.
I'm like,
no,
no thanks bro.
You know,
and then we talk like a week later,
what's going on?
Did I get a fight?
No,
we can't get,
you know,
fight yet unless you want to fight Joe blow or this guy,
you know what I'm like already been sitting out seven months nursing my age is,
I'm already thinking,
yeah,
I'll fight whoever it is,
you know?
So while this is going on,
the reality shows pitching numbers at us to keep increasing the number.
Every time they get to a decent number,
they talked to my manager,
my manager talks to me.
He's like,
yeah,
I can't get,
you know,
fight right now that you want.
Why don't you just go there a couple of weeks,
one to two weeks,
collect these paychecks,
come back.
And that's it.
You know,
and uh,
the,
the reality shows like you go through like a par core,
um,
kind of obstacles and then at the end you've got to aim.
So why your heart rate shot up?
You'd have to like knock down water bottles with a Frisbee or football or
something like that.
But the cool part is that I'm up against an Olympic gymnast,
Park Core Dude's,
um,
tennis players,
soccer players,
all types of athletes were just mix in there.
And we're just all competing in this thing.
So it was pretty cool and it was awesome experience.
I ended up lasting 13 weeks in the show and the show ran for about 15 weeks.
So I got pretty far deep in it,
you know.
And uh,
the coolest thing was that I got to be alone by myself because one of the things
is there's no cell phone,
there's no TV,
there's no music on the show.
So it's just the interaction of us and outside of that,
that's it.
That's your only interactions.
You don't have no interactions with the town.
People are nothing.
They strictly forbid day,
you know,
they want you like case up.
So it was awesome.
I thought,
you know,
after a while I was the best.
I'd go work out in the nature,
be by myself in the mountains or in the beach and just Shannon and you really
get to notice yourself.
And that's why I call it the resurrection,
because I thought about it like all the negative dumb things that have done in
my life and just let me eliminate them,
whether I like them in my life or not.
Let me just eliminate that shit.
And that's it.
You know,
that's what we call it,
the resurrection,
you know?
Yeah.
Well that fight would tell man,
if anybody had any doubts that fight or race to all of them.
And that was a,
I mean,
till was top five,
right?
Yeah.
And so,
uh,
that puts you in the hunt now and what a crazy goddamn division that is now.
Yes,
sir.
I mean,
we got a Robbie Lawler who's,
uh,
he's,
about to fight Tyron Woodley again.
They're going to have a rematch.
That's crazy.
Fucking fine.
It's a crazy funny,
ooh.
Spawn is waiting to see who's going to be next for him at one 70.
Now that he's the champ,
I mean,
Wonderboy,
uh,
just got KL pedis,
which is crazy.
That was crazy.
And now RDA,
which is a ranked 70 pounders going to fight,
uh,
she gonna fight the 55 registers.
Forgot his name right now.
The second Kevin.
Oh yeah,
Kevin Lee's going to go up to 70 now.
So those are the things that throw me off.
Like if,
if pedis stays at 70 awesome.
But if he goes down to 55 we kind of like makes it more of a of a weird set up.
And same thing with Kevin.
The,
I
dunno if he's saying oh a seven year or he's doing like a onetime one night
sending,
you know,
staying according to him.
The more I talked to him,
he just had,
it was just too hard for him.
It's like 55 just ruined him every time he got down there he made it.
What would you,
you've met him,
he's big,
he's a big guy and he's walking around like one 85 easy,
maybe more and thick.
You know,
sound like man,
this is not a lot of weight there that you can cut off three.
See if he stays,
no problem.
I love it,
you know?
But when it's,
when they come and go it like fuck some legislation makes it a labyrinth.
Yeah.
I don't understand why the UFC is so reluctant to have more weight classes.
I really don't get it.
Like Dana said that the 165 pound weight class will never happen while he's
running the UFC and he's going to be running for the next seven years.
He said think it was an ESPN plus Kevin Lee's want to make Rafael dos Anjos
fight at one 65 is asking him to see like if they can make a backroom deal to
just both weigh in at one 65 instead of one 70 just to sort of force it.
That's not forcing it.
Why would I?
That doesn't even make any sense.
That's so weird.
I mean five pounds is not that much of a difference and it's not,
but it would be nice if there was a 10 pound gap.
I don't know.
They both,
uh,
I mean Delsandro says fought successfully at 170.
He looked great when he fought Lawler,
you know,
be magnitude.
Yeah.
But I feel like he's probably a guy that should be one 65 too.
You know they can make it like a one 62 or something like 63 something like
that.
We'll probably just fucking whistling in the wind.
Now they have their ideas.
I look,
I don't want to run that business.
I don't want to tell them what to do.
Fuck riding in that.
Imagine being run in the UFC when a nightmare.
That would be,
it depends on how much money he can pay for it.
Right.
I gas still.
Once you have all that money for a few years and then you're dealing with high
blood pressure and your fucking panic attacks the middle of the night.
I got things for high blood pressure.
They're pretty good.
They do.
Yeah.
Marijuana.
That does help.
What's it like in Florida getting weed?
Is it hard now?
Florida's a fucking mafia man and I'm going to get killed fish,
but you know every state when Eagle and had the flower and shit,
we only had wax.
That's it.
That's it,
man.
That's what medical,
right?
You have to have a medical.
They're literally about to become,
I think flower just became legal in Florida.
Or it's about to become the morning to write.
Yeah.
Medical.
No,
uh,
no.
Just smoking the smoke.
I wonder if they're going to be easy with the medical recommendations,
the way they used to be for opiates,
opiates.
He'd be able to just get people to get oxies with like just go to a doctor,
one of those little pain management centers in Florida.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I'm showing how hard it's going to be to get weed because they obviously there's
someone who spending some money trying to keep it from being fully legal there.
Yes.
Yeah.
And I think a big part of it is because,
uh,
like south Florida culture,
um,
there's a lot of natural growers over there.
They grew like,
it's always been a big business.
It's
illegal,
of course,
to grow marijuana in Florida and selling,
you know,
especially in Miami,
Florida.
And a lot of people did this.
So I think when the rules came about legalizing medical marijuana,
he said,
we're not going to have plans because then everybody's going to grow plants.
And,
you know,
it's like we can't really charge him because it's,
it's legal,
you know?
So that's why I think they did the wax.
Hmm.
Because you can't grow by manufacturer.
Yeah,
I guess.
And I don't really agree.
It's like smoking wax.
Like somebody's giving me wax,
like,
oh,
here's smoke.
This,
I don't really know what's in there.
You know?
I always shoes like that,
uh,
from cocaine to crack people's hours.
So cocaine and then you're fucking crack head,
you know?
So the wax,
I don't care how many times somebody tells me,
no,
this is super safe.
I get it.
You know?
But I rather the flower if I'm going to smoke.
Yeah.
It's pure.
But apparently one of the things we're dealing with in California is pesticides.
Yeah.
At some weed,
uh,
you know,
grown by shitty growers.
It has pesticides on it.
You're smoking these pesticides.
I mean,
this is why it should be legal.
So you could test things,
test things,
and find out what's pure and what's not.
Make things organic.
Only the best of the best.
Make it to that,
to that other side,
you know?
Yeah.
I Dunno.
It's just weird.
It's weird that it's so easy to get opiates in,
uh,
in Florida.
So hard to get weed.
I wouldn't know nothing about that.
I wouldn't know nothing about that either.
So when you look at the landscape now,
um,
you,
you're obviously in the running for a shot at the title.
Has anybody give you any indication of what you would have to do to get a shot
at Uzman or to to be next in line?
The next one is,
is this idiot,
I won't even mention his name on your show because I'm not going to make him
famous.
He's a fucking idiot,
you know,
but fight this guy and then go for the title.
That's what it is,
homey.
So you have to find somebody else.
Yeah.
What is his name?
Ryan with?
Oh,
Dolby.
No,
no,
no.
You don't want to say no.
I was trying to legacy on Edwards.
No,
no,
no.
He just made that guy famous soup.
You made him famous a couple of weeks ago.
I know.
It's,
Oh,
who?
Shmenn.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's right.
You're supposed to fight it.
Ben.
Ask around in July fucking door.
You don't like him now I'm going to be it really home bit.
Not,
not as long as you get the,
that was the fight was scheduled.
Um,
what's,
what's the problem with Ben Grin?
He's,
he's that new age,
you know,
and he's like a fucking 40 [inaudible] but he's said these new ones,
dudes just fucking talk.
Like just talk and talk and talk about everybody.
Shut the fuck up.
Because when you,
when,
when somebody sees you in person,
you're not that guy.
And like I said,
I'm,
I don't come from this technology world.
I come from like if you,
if you say like,
Yo Joe,
you're a fucking idiot.
What are you going to punch me in the face?
Or I better be ready for it.
You know,
I'm just not going around and disrespecting people.
I get taught respect because if not,
somebody's gonna make you respect,
you know?
But these guys nowadays,
daisy grow up with these little things.
Nigga just say whatever the fuck they want.
Words carry weight.
Especially my kids can read your stupid comments.
You know,
my kids have access to the Internet now.
I just don't like them.
You know,
one incident I reminded when Khabib won the title,
right?
And uh,
Ben immediately comes out,
I'm Khabib's Kryptonite,
I would smash them.
Or something like that I for is your 70 pounder.
You fucking moron.
He's a 55 pound there and you're not even in the UFC.
You know,
he's,
he's that type of guy and attention whore.
Look at me,
look at me.
I,
I don't even like his fighting saw.
I like a lot of restaurant style because if that's what you did in your imposing
and,
and when and awesome,
but when your sole purpose is just to hug somebody,
leg is hard as you can.
And then,
I dunno what you think about the Ravi five,
but he didn't win that fight in my eyes,
you know,
was not asleep several times.
We lost our fight several times.
I thought that rob who's asleep for a second and then Ooh,
Swan showed it to me and then I changed my mind.
And then herb dean came on and talked about and I changed my mind again because
herb dean was saying that what he was concerned with was the way the arm dropped
and that it was a cervical lock.
The essentially when you have a bulldog choke it puts,
uh,
puts us some serious leverage on your neck.
He's like,
and he's seen guys go out from that and their whole body goes paralyzed and he
saw a guy,
uh,
where that happened to it and he came back.
He is,
he got his movement back again but for awhile it was pretty fucking scary.
So he was getting choked out,
you know,
by getting his neck pinched.
It was pinching down the nerve.
He was worried that that was happening with Robbie said the ways arm dropped.
He goes,
it wasn't normal and he goes at it and he gave me some serious concern.
Um,
Ben asked her and said that he let go of the choke a little bit when herb came
over to him cause he thought herb is going to stop it cause he thought Robbie
was out and he thinks that during that time when he let go,
Robbie came back to life,
which could have happened.
I don't know.
It's hard for me to say,
but I feel like in herb dean situation,
I think he did the right thing cause the arm dropping was fucking weird and
yeah.
Yeah.
The arm driving was a little weird.
But he wasn't out.
I never seen nobody go to sleep during it.
No.
I seen people go to sleep.
Ashley,
Evan Smith went to sleep with the thumbs up,
thumbs up.
But the what,
here's what the herb said that made sense.
He goes,
was it the thumbs up?
I want a thumbs up if someone looks at me,
I want this.
It's not,
is your arm down on that position?
Was it this,
did he do this or it was his arm down.
I don't know.
Only Robbie knows whether or not he was out.
He says he wasn't.
So you have to also say he's in the middle of war.
If it's up to me,
I want the guy to go peace sign with the cheese.
The guy's defending the choke with a story.
You know he did.
That was the other thing that herb said he didn't grab for the choke.
He said the natural defense would be to get,
get his hands on the on the hands and tried to separate them.
He didn't do that.
He said
just natural defense Robbie
cause he seen this guy do it has a fucking a thing,
you know maybe Robbie can be put to sleep from.
There's guys that are weird like that,
that just certain positions they could go 30 minutes,
you're choking them and then they don't go to see.
Maybe Robbie's,
that guy all knows he wasn't sleeping.
Yeah.
Well that's what Robbie said.
Robbie said that he was waiting for band attires arms out.
That's what he said.
He said he felt the tie,
the squeeze,
the squeeze really tight,
but he's like,
I'll just let him gasses arms out here.
That was his thought look mean.
Michael [inaudible] said that when Kevin Lee got his back and they stopped the
fight before he went out,
he said,
I let my hands go because I was concentrating on my neck.
I was just tightening up by NACC and,
and trying to keep my blood flowing.
I think that one was a little different than it was over naked,
you know?
Yeah.
It was different.
You're going to go to sleep eventually
and that one,
let a guy go to sleep like that one.
You should let a guy go to sleep and Adam.
Yeah,
nothing happens.
You need to just wake them right up.
Hey,
you went to sleep.
Go Big that maybe they pee their pants while they went to sleep.
No big deal.
It's certain net cracks where you just go,
oh no,
but that one's not going to put you in a wheelchair.
Not especially not from Ben's asthma problem.
So your take is on all of this,
uh,
trash talking media hype shit that you see going on now.
You don't like it?
I don't even know.
I think,
uh,
I fast forward,
it's not like it's distasteful right now to some point,
but if you just fast forward to the guys like me when I was 14 years old
watching the sport,
now you're looking at the dude's right not doing it.
You're going to grow up and think,
oh well I got to do the same shit.
I just got to fucking talk shit.
Lot of shit.
I don't really gotta to go to the gym that much.
She's got to have a banging lit social network account and I'm fucking Golden,
you know?
And we see it,
you know,
a sage Northcutt for example,
great tans and stuff,
but um,
what he was getting paid out.
Did it make sense?
So a lot of the fighters,
you know,
why,
why was he getting paid so much?
Because of the social media is,
but as he really bringing in those people into the chairs and into the TV,
because you have a lot of likes,
you know,
the things that I wonder,
not like to disagreement and them,
but sometimes girls have like tremendous amount of followers,
you know.
Do those numbers translate to viewers on the TV or,
or like butts and seats or any of that?
Like I would like to know,
you know,
and a lot of times when I've asked like people in the UFC and stuff,
they say no,
those numbers don't translate.
So what did they get more money?
You know,
I'm not talking about the girls get more money than I was.
I'm talking about guys that have like a social media presence that are just
getting more money.
We'll just kinda translate certain amount.
No,
I'm sure it does.
I'm sure
guys like Colby Colby has got to translate.
I mean he's,
he talks so much shit.
He gets people excited about the fights.
There's something to it.
I don't know.
I just,
I appreciate what you're saying though.
And I look,
I appreciate the way one fc handles things cause they concentrate on just
fighters being honorable and fighting their best and find the best fighters they
can fight.
And they don't emphasize that shit talking at all.
They emphasize the martial arts aspect of I get it,
me and you like each other.
John Jones and DC.
I love it.
Cause you
feel these guys don't like each other.
You feel it.
Kill each other,
you know,
but to me it's okay,
but he's doing it.
When Max Holloway fought Dustin,
there was none of that.
There was just two guys who were the best in their weight class.
I mean Max is the best hundred and 45 pound ever.
And Dustin [inaudible] is absolutely one of the best wine at 55 pounders alive.
And they're going to go after it.
And it was beautiful.
It was beautiful.
It was a parking,
just biting them,
fighting,
shaking hands,
full respect before and after.
Yeah.
And I get a lot of people like they have that,
uh,
I hate using,
you're moving into a fight so they don't want to shake hands.
Like,
fuck you,
I don't like you,
you know,
but when,
when they're giving so much attention to that WWF stuff and pushing you to the
forefront that,
um,
let me let you know,
and just to think that the kids watching it are going to be even worse.
They're going to do it to the next power.
Did,
did you get up,
I mean,
when,
when you went over and got into a fight with Leon,
you were being interviewed,
he was yelling some shit at you while you're being interviewed and you walked
over.
And one of the,
one of the things that I like what you said is he walked over your hands behind
your back.
You're like,
look what,
just talk.
Say what the fuck you want to say to me.
But then when he was standing in front of you like you wanted to punch you,
you're like,
okay
Ma,
you know,
at first or initially,
um,
I was doing my interview and he's crossing by and he's with his corner man.
And I dunno if this guy consumes a lot of drugs or what that he thought that
that would intimidate.
He means he was walking like this looking at me and like pacing back and forth
and I'm trying to do my interview,
you know,
and he asked me something about something,
a date and I say maybe,
maybe not.
And then he tells me to shut up,
you know.
Well everybody watching his back home from Miami who was like,
you should've punched him as soon as he asked you a question while you're
interview,
because that's my natural inkson.
You know,
if you're getting interviewed and some fucking idiot comes here and cuts your
interior off,
but you should get punched or slapped upside your head,
you know,
that'll teach you respect not to do it and nobody else again,
I should immediately done it,
but I didn't,
I answered his question politely.
Maybe,
maybe not.
He goes on to say,
shut up after that.
I can't take that.
My daughter might be watching this interview.
I'm been telling her,
stand up to bullies your whole life.
Don't go running to somebody and tell him as soon.
So is picking on me.
Handle it yourself.
That's what's wrong with this country.
I think with this whole,
somebody picks on you.
Go tell somebody else.
I'm not going to tell authorities this hooligans picking on me.
I'm gonna handle it myself,
you know,
because I got to see him again.
He's gonna think he could pick on me.
Got To handle it myself.
You know,
I'm in my interview,
man.
You're gonna steal my moment.
I just worked out here.
Just kicked some butt out here.
You barely want to split decision in your own country.
I knocked this dude out and you're trying to steal my shine like this.
That,
that's what I'm saying like,
and then he got famous off that,
which I hate.
So only thing I could take back about that night,
that it wasn't filmed that and filmed it,
it'd be even better.
You know,
he was just gone off and sign this,
you know,
neon God has asked to helped you too.
Did it help me?
Yeah,
but it helped him more than anything.
No,
it helps people know who the school knows.
Mosfet all doesn't take any shit.
People have known that since they light before rainbows had color.
They already knew that man.
They didn't,
they didn't need to see me whooping.
They like to see it.
They'd like to get remembered though.
Yeah.
They like to see people have consequences for shit.
Talking in this weird era of constant shit talking,
you know?
I think people enjoy it.
They like it.
And if you guys ever fight,
but makes it a bigger fight for sure.
My Gosh,
man,
you know me guess,
but does that like I beat number city.
I've been in this sport for a while.
I've been beating up guys.
Would that validate them to fight me when I don't eat in the top 10 guy?
You still yet to be the top 10 guy,
you know,
like,
but he could get that fight off that,
that,
that's the new age and era.
That.
Right?
Right.
That's a concern.
I'll fuck when when his,
when he's beating the top Tim Guy,
I'm going to be the first guy to expose him to break his face,
but until that moment comes,
you're,
you're talking about the business side because you already saw on the personal
side,
any day of the week I will address you,
but on the business side,
get to my level buddy,
put in the fucking word.
Go beat a top 10 guy.
Knock him the fuck out.
Did you talk about getting in trouble for punching somebody in another country?
I was scared out of my fucking life,
Joe.
That's what I'm thinking.
I was scared of.
I thought this guy was going to kill me,
man.
I might've not looked it,
but I was scared out of my life.
Yeah,
I get it.
I'm very cold blooded.
You know,
I get that from,
from genetics,
from my pops in them,
but I was scared out of my mind.
I thought this guy was going to take everything I had.
You know,
you had to do that.
I had to defend.
I understand,
but did you worry at all about them arresting you or any weird shit like that
over there?
I mean you,
you're in another corner to press charges.
I,
that's how scared I was.
But I'm not going to press charges because I understand how my man,
but that's how I felt.
You were in danger.
I was fucking hell of in danger and just do not see it was not just one say it.
And he's just him and his crew of hooligans.
Hooligans,
lawless people.
I had to defend myself.
I did everything in my right to defend myself.
It was one against like three or four dudes and they know it.
It's on video.
Okay,
I understand.
And so the,
with the police say to that,
oh they ain't telling me nothing man.
They didn't tell you shit.
I didn't speak to know polices.
That's amazing.
No,
no police for me.
No talking to anyways in the Spanglish,
immediately we go on mute and I looked to get English.
Huh?
Okay.
And then pick English.
Yeah.
I mean how many times he fought England before the war.
First Time.
Yeah.
So like if you've go the rest of your career and you can't go to England.
Oh well no,
that would show up.
I really liked England.
Did you?
Fans are so knowledgeable and they were just cool.
Even the ones who were like till fans and we said like a funny joke to me or
something cool.
But it wasn't like that weird bad energy,
you know?
Even if there were till fans,
but just be like,
oh my boy,
Jill's going to get,
you
know,
but it'd be like funny and how they say cheeky,
you know,
it was,
it was a great experience everywhere I went and the people were super,
super duper cool.
Yeah.
Um,
Brazil's rough.
If someone's fighting a Brazilian.
Yeah,
they don't,
I've heard this story.
I have yet to find a solution for nationalistic and proud.
Very proud.
So they're not into people coming over there and fight and Brazilians and I got
to be friendly to you.
Yeah.
But England's different men,
they're very polite,
very knowledgeable.
Every one of the countries has been around for a while with the sport.
Yeah.
What'd you think about that style?
Bender gasoline fight.
Oh,
that was pretty good,
man.
That was wild.
Shadi good tested both.
Both tests.
Exam both tested Cason.
Who's got a ton of heart?
Ooh,
he's a tank was nobody.
He didn't get mad at him.
If in the fifth round he said,
you know what?
Yeah,
he just fucking kept going.
Stop Dell again.
Survived.
I mean just how incredible it looked like style band and was going to take him
out several times.
Yeah,
I mean what a fight and to have Calvin land the first big shot early on and drop
style bender and show him some real adversity and let them know,
hey man,
do you can get knocked the fuck out in this fight.
You know that that was a,
that was a real awesome moment,
man.
What a fight too,
Back and forth.
Yep.
Ooh,
so much chaos and till have Calvin head kick him and rock him.
How bout that shit?
The thing that really rock style bender with a fucking head cake from Calvin.
Calvin would press him up against the cage,
maybe get a take down,
but just definitely keep them up against the Cajun work them there.
You know,
with his wrestling background went,
I didn't,
I didn't see that going like that,
you know?
Yeah.
There was some wild scrambles on the ground too.
Was Towel Bennett threw up that fucking triangles.
Like whoa,
he's got a game on the ground.
He said gifted athlete and fast as fuck,
man,
there's more than just gifted.
He you could tell you that puts in the work 100% and he's smart as fuck.
Yeah,
he's smart and creative and just has a broad encyclopedia of,
of,
first of all striking knowledge.
But obviously when he went to the ground,
he knew what the fuck to do man.
He was throwing up triangles.
He locked Kelvin up in a triangle.
It's just they're slippery and it's the end of the fight and you know,
he popped out of it with all,
obviously Kevin use the right technique to get out of it too.
But that was a serious fucking triangle attempt.
This is a serious fight.
Me.
That was a good areas for your hard earned money for that fight.
Oh yeah.
Well I hope um enough people got a chance to watch it cause I dunno what that
ESPN plus Debaca was.
Cause apparently there were a bunch of people that couldn't get it.
Like there was,
she had a sign up rate to the APP and there were some crashes and some people
wouldn't work on their device and they had an order it online then it still
didn't work.
So on paper views now bought through ESPN?
Yes.
Oh I didn't know that.
I thought it was just like some,
no,
it's all of them from now on.
So can you have direct TV?
Tough Shit.
You got to get it through ESPN plus I think it's a good move because I think in
the future that's where everything's going to be.
I think the UFC just got way ahead of it.
Whereas most people are still like boxing matches and shit.
You're getting,
most of them,
you're getting them off of a paper view on Directv or cable or whatever the fuck
you use.
But now they're using that disown,
you know,
does zone has a lot of uh,
fights you get from that APP and a lot of boxing matches.
The ones just signed Canelo to that huge,
huge deal.
They signed triple G.
Yes.
You know,
so they're doing a lot of streaming shit too.
Yeah.
I saw a commercial with the other day at Dave and Buster's with a Tracy Morgan,
anything.
Hmm.
Yeah,
yeah.
Streaming I think is the future.
And I think that's why the design got way ahead of it.
And then ESPN plus getting way ahead of it too.
I think they see where the writing on the wall is just from here to there to
take a little bit of time because people,
everybody's used to just pay per view is a TV,
you know,
I think whatever Comcast people going to get used to having their TV connected
to the Internet,
there's a lot of fucking people that don't have their TV connected to the
Internet,
you know?
So once people start using,
yeah,
once people start using like apple TV and connect through that and then get the
APP through apple or use a,
you know,
a android or whatever the fuck they use to get online.
It'll be normal to have that on your TV in five years.
But right now it's,
it's rough.
If you don't have that and you want to see the fights
or if you come from the stone and you'd like me,
you've got an internet labyrinth.
It's,
it gets crazy,
man.
Yeah.
I wonder how the pay structure works.
Like,
say if you get a title fight and say you beat ass grin and then you get a title
fight with Guzman,
um,
what men,
how do they do that with ESPN plus as opposed to like paper view points or
something like that.
That's so true,
man.
How does that work?
Oh yeah.
Look at you like you're in pain.
No,
I've got,
I'm using brainpower
and require it requires energy.
That's why there's this gentleman by the name of Abraham cow and let them do it.
All that man.
It's good move.
Yeah,
let Ayp handle it.
he's been there.
Done that.
Negotiated bigger contracts in mine.
So just Haber,
take care of me.
You know.
Now this aspirin fight,
um,
you're,
you're fighting him in July.
That what does that,
July 6th?
Yes sir.
Um,
when do you like how much of a camp do you give yourself?
How much of like a fully dedicated,
just all in camp,
all day.
Every day.
All Day.
If you look at them from skillset,
Ben's not even worth waking up before like 10:00 AM in the morning.
But I don't like this dude,
man,
before my alarm goes off,
I'm already awake.
I want to break his fucking face,
man on a break,
his fucking rib cage.
And I don't want to knock them out early on.
I don't,
I just want to hurt towards you.
That guy,
man,
if I get the chance to torture him 14 minutes and 50 seconds before I stop him,
that's what I'm going to do,
man.
You know,
I just,
I don't like to dude at all.
Met him a long time ago.
He's a fucking break man.
I don't like me.
There's not too many people that I generally dislike.
He's one of them.
You know,
if I was a senior right now,
probably wouldn't be friendly of a greeting,
you know?
Now do you base this on how he talks shit and just plays around and tries to
hype things up?
Or if you had a like a real conversation with them,
combination of things,
you know,
uh,
like,
um,
I'm the type of dude that,
if we,
if we train you go to American top team Joe,
and let's say I get lucky and I tap you out twice.
I'm not going to ever tell nobody that because I,
that's not my glory moment.
That's just fucking training.
I don't give a fuck about that.
I already forgot about that.
But there's some people and they violate that man cold of Jim and the,
I went to American top team and it like,
he's that type of,
of Pussy,
you know,
and I go,
he's talking about Jim stores.
He came over to American top team after I dumped him on his head.
We kept wrestling,
he got scrambled me and he said it.
Yeah,
you beat me rushing with,
we were straight wrestling,
two time national champion.
You're proud of that.
You're telling people that,
you know,
and,
uh,
it,
it just shows me his character,
you know,
he's not,
he's not who he pretends to be.
And then he talks so much online and then I could have respected them a little
bit if he had held to his guns.
But I see him in London and as soon as I seen him,
I start walking towards him.
He goes,
hey man,
ah,
I'm going to spare you.
I'm not going to say nothing to after your fight,
Ben.
Don't do me no fucking favors,
bro.
You're not doing me no favors.
Say whatever the fuck you want when you want it.
You know?
And,
and I dressed him and I went up to talk to him and UFC got involved.
He put his head down and they escorted him out of the hotel and he never came
back to that hotel,
you know?
And he actually wished me good luck at some point too,
like right before,
like,
why are you doing this,
man?
You're not that person on,
on,
on social media that you portray to be.
You're not,
you know,
so you're,
you're fake as fuck.
You're selling something to the public that is not there obviously,
and you're a coward.
Fuck it.
Let's throw that in there too.
And if people don't believe me,
tune in July six I'll show you what,
how much of a coward he is.
Just to play devil's advocate,
don't you think that what he's doing is smart marketing to play devils?
I know you don't like it.
I know you don't like it,
but to play devil's advocate,
but it's corny though.
I when he looks back,
it's Corny.
Like ain't nobody going,
oh,
he just wants validation.
He wants to be accepted.
I think half of what he's doing is corny on purpose.
All that.
Boom roasted shit.
Come on,
man.
Half that stuff is corny on purpose.
No,
no,
no.
That guy,
you haven't seen him and you haven't hung around with that guys.
Just fucking corny.
It's in his DNA.
I like talking to him.
He's a smart motherfucker.
It might be smart man,
but he's appointing motherfucker
and he's this cocky for all the wrong reasons.
I just can't wait.
I love the fact that you're a purist like this though.
I really do.
I want to hurt that.
I know you do.
I want to hurt that dude.
It's going to be a great fight.
It's,
it's one of those interesting fights because you've got good wrestling,
takedown defense.
You've got very good wrestling.
You gotta good,
very good.
Takedowns yourself,
but you clearly have a big advantage and striking,
so it's one of those Ken he imposes will kind of get ahold of you.
You to get ahold of these fucking nuts,
man.
Wow.
They'll say to my face in minute,
cool bro,
I'm a punk,
or whatever you call,
you shared it to my face,
you know,
but you'd see it online.
It's just the hallway get said about you see it online and then when you see me
with what's up,
hey,
how are you eating?
Picture
fucking kidding me,
man.
The fuck is,
I feel like I've been brought up from like a twilight zone.
It from a different dimension.
Sometimes there's a lot of these rapper fighters that you see acting like
criminals on the social media when they see me,
hey,
what's up bro?
Let me get a picture off fucking fanboyed out.
Oh Man,
I could have sworn you were just mentioning my name.
Seen some shit,
bro.
It's fucking nuts to me.
Most of my mind.
Right.
I'm such a simpleton boy.
It just blows my mind.
Every thought.
Europe purist.
I don't know if it's a pure and simple.
I don't know where you want to put me,
but it's simple.
Just don't want to play that game.
You're not interested in that game.
It's mine.
Listen,
Khabib on isn't that fucking game either,
but he was on top of Connor.
Let's talk now.
Bam.
Let's talk.
Let's talk now.
Same Shit purist.
I love it.
I do.
I appreciate when that shit talking has consequences.
I like some shit talking though.
It's fun
when you back it up.
Yeah.
Back that shit up.
Now you see me in a hallway lobby and fucking run to security and get a squirt
it down.
Who's the guy you fought in the past you had the most beef with before you
actually fought?
Uh,
I don't know.
I never really had like real deep,
so not like this fight,
like telling you went back and forth a little bit,
right?
No,
no,
no.
We went back and forth like,
Hey,
you want to fight yet?
A steward.
I fuck it.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
But we never even,
it was pretty respected.
Yeah.
It was a cool dude,
man.
What about cowboy?
Cowboy?
I mean,
yeah,
a little bit of beef.
You know,
nothing crazy.
Like if I see him in the street,
we went and start fucking fighting or nothing.
You know?
Is that what you mean by like beef or just like we were going back and forth
talking shit to each other like,
yeah,
mean Cambodia,
you buy me Calvin,
we're talking a lot of shit back and forth to each other,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
It was coming from genuine places,
from both sides,
you know?
So it was good.
It made,
it gave that fire,
you know?
Yeah,
that's definitely one.
It came from like a little bit of light.
This aspirin one,
I respect the cap.
We're going into that fight.
You know,
obviously he's,
I think he's a fucking stud bone.
He proves it again,
by having the most wins.
Most knockouts,
emissions,
dude's a stud.
I,
I don't think aspirins even yet to get a wind in the UFC.
You know,
I just think about it like if I had fought Robbie Lawler,
which was a great champion and has done amazing things in the sport since the
start of Robbie to now by the guy still fight him.
And I remember watching him in the UFC back back in the day 37
and a half with the fuck discounts when he came along and a half deal fucking
lean.
People still call it looked amazing.
It looks,
yeah,
it looked fucking amazing.
What's amazing physically when he hoisted ask her up in the air and dumped him
on his head and then started just driving his fucking knuckles through his
brain.
And it shows you how tough askern is.
The dude's durable is fucked man.
He handled that.
He's built for survival even by his body type.
You can tell that physiologically he's just built for a guy like me to put them
under the radar like,
Oh,
this guy's not a threat.
Look at him,
you know,
but it's not going to work.
I already know what to do to this guy and just fucking hurt a man.
Even the way he's fucking bill is for patheticness.
Let's skip the subject matters to go to somebody else,
man.
I met this guy famous on your show.
Well,
it's too late.
Too late.
Well,
listen man,
they put his picture up on the,
on the marquee.
He gets a big pop.
It's crazy.
People love it.
Ask Him.
I guess.
I don't know.
I haven't seen him.
Loved him before.
He fought in the UFC too.
I had never seen that because I saw an England and England.
They didn't fucking hated his ass man.
They were born them out of the fucking stage and she looks like he belongs
there.
Right?
It looks like,
ah,
you're left us lad.
He looks like an English guy.
Doesn't need,
I guess man does not like a,
what do you think his nationality is?
Aspirin.
He looks like he probably has some English in him.
Curly hair.
White English dudes and curly hair.
Yeah,
you got it.
He's got a while.
That's wrestling style,
wrestling style.
It's funky.
It's very unusual.
Very effective.
You know he's going to have that wrestle Mattrick Jordan Burroughs.
She doesn't get smashed.
Is that before or after yours?
I think you said before.
Does that concern you?
And you might get injured doing that.
I don't give a fuck if he does this because he faked an injury out.
You know,
he knows what he's doing.
He's a big boy.
You know?
It's like if you're going to fight Joe Romeo and uh,
one of your teammates might come up to you and tell you like,
hey man,
I think you should fake the injury in the Drake.
What drove him?
I would just fake the injury and cop out of that fight.
You don't want no,
no problems with that guy,
you know?
So that might be what he's trying to do.
Who knows?
Man.
Damn.
Fucking 185 pound division.
We were Maryland.
What a division now.
Now with style vendor and gas,
Tulum and then style benders.
Gonna Fight Whitaker and I hope you're well fights board.
Cina they're supposed to fight,
right?
Paulo Kosta that they're supposed to fight.
I don't know.
I thought I knew he was gonna Fight Jaggery then Joel got her and Yo al was
supposed to fight,
um,
Paulo first,
but then someone got hurt there.
It might've been Paulo,
but Paul's healed up again and the Jacques Rey fights out and so they set a new
fight up for Shakuri.
So [inaudible] he's got an opponent and now Yo el doesn't
man.
It's fucking crazy division.
Now that division is a real shark tank.
Tell you truth.
I would like to see Joel fight for the title cause I feel now take nothing away
from Whittaker guy.
I think he's one of the baddest dude on the planet.
I feel [inaudible] I feel like you went to the second fight.
The first fight straight or with a good one.
The second one I straight up thought Joel One.
I was actually there in his corner and I was like,
oh we got this.
Wow.
You know,
he won the third round one,
the fourth one,
the fifth.
And also with the damage,
significant damage with the new world.
I think,
I don't know if they use the new scorecards,
the new scoring method,
but if they did and he didn't win then it's a real travesty.
But he had,
he had him hurt and that wasn't a 10,
eight round original ten seven.
What's the big difference in that fight?
In my opinion,
Robert Whitaker for sure scored.
He fought well,
he won rounds.
But when you allow hurt him,
he really fucking hurt him.
And there was no moments like that for Whitaker where he had UL staggered and
almost out Winokur's I'll fucking based on at superintelligent Duda when he
fights man him and stop and it's going to be very unusual cause that's a,
that's a big step up to go from uh,
from style bender to go from the very first fight in the UFC,
which was only like a year and a half ago,
all the way up to Robert Whitaker in a year and a half.
It's amazing.
It's an amazing step up.
Whitaker's something special.
And he's another guy that was a one 70 just cut and way too much weight.
Couldn't do it.
Went up to one 85 and really found his own place.
So many guys,
I think they're in that category,
whether it'd be healthier if they went up.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
But when you saw Holloway versus poor,
Yay.
Did you get the impression that really Holloway should stay at one 45 mm?
Yes and no,
because I,
I know personally [inaudible] I know he packs a punch,
so I don't think it's like all your career 55 is done.
Max know you fought one of the,
the more clever,
powerful punches because one of the better boxer,
one of the better box and,
and to the nit and gritty of it,
man,
dps like a broader,
you know,
he's,
he likes her bra,
but an intelligent one,
you know,
he wants to hit you as much as he can without getting hit.
Very greedy,
you know?
And uh,
I think it was just a bad fight for Max.
I think Mexican fucking,
there's a lot of guys max murders at one 55 I think.
You know,
I think so too.
But I think at one 45 he's almost unstoppable.
Yeah.
That,
I don't even know how he makes one 45.
I don't know how it makes it either,
but when he gets down there,
man,
he's just something special.
He doesn't,
it doesn't seem to diminish him in his performance.
I'll give you look at its performance against Ortega.
He can make it,
he can make that weight and once he gets there,
man,
good luck catching up.
That gas tank of his is credible.
This,
it's incredible.
Footwork,
timing,
uh,
the fakes that he throws it,
he switches up and then he explodes and then he fakes fakes and he explodes as,
I love his rhythm and patch.
Yeah.
Very,
very great at distant management and also switching stances and being creative
and never always giving you a different look.
Yes.
He's,
he's amazing man.
He's a special guy.
He really is.
He's in my pound for pound this,
you know,
might as well.
And he takes a loss like a fucking man.
I mean,
just takes that loss so well.
He now,
he's like,
hey,
it is what it is.
He's a great
champion.
He beat a champion,
you know?
No,
I'm still the champ at one 45 it's like laughing and shit.
Like he,
he took,
he gave everything he had.
He came up short,
no excuses and,
and full respect to Dustin.
It was great man.
Maybe a year or two from the,
I can run it back 100% copa fires from me.
He's only 27 yeah.
That's even crazier.
Already.
The best featherweight of all time.
One of the best pound for pound fighters for sure on the planet earth.
Only 27 he's good.
And his grappling defensively,
he's pretty fucking good.
Yeah.
He throws his chokes up and shit.
You can do everything.
Scary dude.
Yeah,
he does everything.
He really does.
I mean,
it's a,
it's an amazing time for the sport really is.
There's so much talent right now.
I wish you still had the 25 division.
I,
I liked that division.
Well they still kind of do,
I mean Benevidez is still,
uh,
still trying to set up something,
you know,
and if so Hutto goes up and beat smile Mris and decides to still defend his
hundred 25 pound title,
that's a huge fight.
Fight.
Marlin's a scary cat.
Yeah,
he's just scary cat.
But Shawshee judo.
Oh yeah.
Wow.
I remember when Judah won that gold medal we were watching.
I was,
we were already like fans of him and stuff and he came over to American top team
not long afterwards and a user already working on and he said,
no,
I'm going to keep brushing,
but I want to fight him.
And Jimmy and I remember watching him,
uh,
this guy work out.
He was like maybe 20,
21 cause he was,
he,
I think he's the youngest gold medalist ever in at least American history.
I don't know if all wrestling history.
So I remember watching him work and I was like,
man,
that dude,
one day we'll do something big in this sport.
If he commits to it.
The way he did the wrestling and showing off,
he's done fucking huge thing.
Well,
the way took out Tj,
I definitely thought it was an early stoppage,
but I definitely thought Tj was fucked.
He was in a bad place and if so,
who knows if they'd just let it go for another 10 15 seconds.
He might've shut the lights out on Tj and we don't,
we don't know.
But the fact that he just staggered them and just came out right off the bat and
just start dropping bombs on Tj.
I mean that,
that just show and again,
the backgrounds in wrestling,
she shows you what an athlete he is and how quick he learns when he fought
Wilson Hayes and all of sudden it's fighting like karate fighter.
Remember that he was standing sideways and then he drops like blitz,
right?
Hands on.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
Like look at how he's fighting the fact that he can incorporate all these
different styles too.
He's something special.
Endurance,
power,
speed and success.
You know the guy,
the first guy ever to be an Olympic gold medalist and wrestling and then a UFC
world champion.
A beats the best guy ever,
ever,
ever.
You know what I mean?
It's amazing.
He's an,
he's an amazing guy.
Something else to me.
That's another guy that the right books on.
Yup.
Whoa.
That's another scary fucker.
Yeah.
He's uh,
he's a special guy.
I'm a,
I hope he get fucking
paid over there at one FC.
I really do.
And they have a deep talent pool over there.
They have littler guys in Asia.
You know there's a lot of guys over there for him
and they got a lot of a,
I know they bring in a lot
of good Muay Thai guys,
which I know mighty should just scoop them up and put them on the head but still
be fun and still be fun to say cause those high level Thai guys are fucking
something else.
Mighty mouse is entertain the idea of having grappling matches over in one fc
and even maybe possibly kickboxing matches.
They want to say,
cause you know,
they do everything over there.
One FC has a fucking huge audience,
man.
And you know,
they're talking about 40,
80 million people are watching you to vet each event Nasia no way.
And all throughout the world.
Yeah.
It's giant.
And they hear it over here in America too.
I think it was on the encore network.
I was flipping through the channels and a,
it was on,
I was like Whoa.
Okay.
So it's on,
it's on TV in America too.
I had no idea.
Yeah,
it was after the fact.
It wasn't live.
I mean I think you could watch it live on bleacher report live.
There was a website,
right?
You Watch it on bleacher report live,
what the day of the event.
And I think it was free,
wasn't it?
Uh,
find that out.
I think it was anyway.
Um,
it was free to watch the replay on television and flick.
They got fucking high level athletes.
That Guy Nasty Ucan who knocked out every Alvarez that cause the guy's legit as
fuck.
You could take out Eddie Alvarez like that.
You're legit as fuck and got some Thai guys.
Twitter.
Gary was scaring them.
225 fucking Thai fights.
How about yachts and clot?
How about they got yachts and Clive fighting with MMA gloves on almost.
See,
Ooh,
he's so dangerous to let him fight Thai style.
But with MMA gloves it's like I love it man.
I fucking love that.
That's how they get to like they get tagged their grips a little better than
maybe the take downs are going to come out a little better there and the shell
does not work as well.
Yeah,
exactly.
The shell,
the hands come sneak through little spots and that's what happened with him and
Andy Sour and with our glass.
Oof.
It's what happens when these like high level strikers come into high level like
MMA.
Amazed.
They think they're safe.
When you're fucking not say perfect examples,
go con Saki and Kaleel Roundtree round.
She's just snuck that beautiful straight left right down the pipe.
Boot ain't dropped him.
Did you see Roundtree in his last fight?
No.
Holy Shit.
Against Eric Anders this weekend.
Holy Shit Dude.
Fucking Holy Shit.
Massacre this to shut out.
It was the best he's ever looked.
He went to Thailand.
Apparently after he got knocked out by Johnnie Walker,
he got hit with an elbow in the clinch and decided I really need to work on his
clinch game.
So he,
he moved to Thailand and he was there for the entire camp.
Put all this shit up on his Instagram,
all these videos and training footage.
He looks sensational,
but when you see him live against Eric and he came out like a Thai guy light on
the front leg,
hands up in the class and just brutalized him.
Shit.
Brutalized,
hitched,
pitched up fucking shutout man against Anders.
Who's that savage?
I watch those.
I mean,
I knew what we knew.
Roundtree was good,
but there was a,
just a giant leap between the round tree of pre Thailand and Post Thailand the
most I've ever seen a guy improve in in two fights.
Shit.
Amazing.
Yeah.
Look at the significant strike differential.
63 more significant strikes.
He landed,
but it was the way he did it,
man.
It was the highest significant strike differential.
That's crazy.
Oh,
that's from that event.
But that's all good and everything like that.
But it was what it looked like.
His switch kick to the inside thigh was insane.
It was self Fahey such a big guy,
man.
Yeah.
Have to be as fast as he was.
No,
no.
Uh,
no telegraphing anything.
It was like,
like over and over again.
And he was all Thai style.
It was really interesting to watch,
man.
He just embraced it and came out way better.
It was a surprise when he got gold called Lake that,
you know,
but I also knew he could happen because it's,
it's not kickboxing.
And I think Goldman's a stud kickboxer man ain't guys fucking good and
kickboxing man.
Oh yeah.
For his weight to shit that he does,
he moves like a 55 pounds.
I was surprising to see that.
You know,
Brown tree has a ridiculously fast trait left.
It's,
he caught Anders with it a bunch of times too.
He dropped him and let's at least three times backgrounds.
Rustling or no,
he's,
it's a Stryker.
Stryker,
yeah.
It's background striking.
He's a beast man.
I mean there's some,
I mean it'll be a while before anybody's excited about anybody fighting Jon
Jones.
Cause it's like,
what do you got?
You know,
you got a dude who's just,
there's certain guys like remember when Anderson was in his prime and it like,
like what are you going to,
who are you going to throw at him?
There was nobody there to,
Weidman came along,
everybody that they threw it up and you're like,
hmm,
what's Anderson going to do to this dude?
When's Annison got a knockout?
You should know Cami.
When's he going to connect on this guy?
And I think that we're in that situation now with John,
you know,
we've got the Tiago Santos fight that's coming up.
It should be interesting.
Yeah.
But it's just the interesting thing is that Santos is a murderous Stryker.
Is he going to be able to connect?
That's the,
that's what makes it interesting.
I think Jones at some of the best defense,
the best
grappling in striking just doesn't get hit.
Distance side kick to your fucking knee cap is no longer there.
And then when you fucking thinking about that sidekick boom,
left elbow to the IEEE orbital.
Yup.
It's a tough puzzle.
He's letting he's,
he doesn't,
he isn't.
He's not light on his feet fees just right there in front of you,
like an unmovable for us.
You know,
it's just going to stand right there in front of you.
He's not going to go back or nothing.
It's just
if he catches you catching a break,
he tried to take a breath,
breath of air.
WHAP whap porn it on.
So it's kicking your legs front,
kicking you in the body over and over and over.
He sees you slowing down.
He's a Predator,
man.
I wish.
Like they can make a science experiment.
Make mighty mouse tool five.
I make that fight happened or shrink Jon Jones and make that fight happen.
Yeah,
no shit.
Right.
No Shit.
That would be crazy.
That would be,
yeah.
See the thing is no tool five or can move like mighty mouse moves.
You would have to see how can mighty mouse move it?
Two Oh five yeah.
Cause the thing gravity.
Yeah.
There's no gravity fucking with him.
When he's won 25 he's fucking to cut and angles and he's,
where is he?
You know,
he's on your legs.
He's,
he could do everything.
But it's technique though is also,
that's right.
When I see him doing the things like kick soccer,
fucking tie dude shoots a double leg,
like a fucking good wrestling dude.
It's not like just an athletic guy.
This explosive,
everything is done just right.
You know,
same thing with John.
he's got great technique everywhere.
Yeah.
I mean Matt Hume has produced some great fighters,
but then there's mighty mouse.
Like he's produced some great talent,
He's like stands way out.
And you gotta wonder like is it mighty mouse?
Is it Madyoon putting more emphasis on him?
Is it a combination of things?
Cause you usually when you get a guy that's that good,
you get a gym that starts producing multiple champions.
Like that usually.
Right.
They get to that area like that pankration is not known for having that kind of
talent other than him.
It was like him.
Josh Barnett.
Yeah.
Josh Barnett came from there.
So put Josh trained everywhere.
Now.
Josh started his career there,
but he's basically been everywhere.
Is Matt Hume open to like the public?
Anybody just walking?
I think so.
I mean,
he has regular classes,
the whole deal,
but I know he gave a lot of specialized attention to mighty mouse also.
He just felt like mighty mouse was a real sponge.
You know,
you really learned as well.
Yeah.
For a fact.
That guy does everything.
Good man.
What do you think you gonna do when you retire?
I Dunno.
Yeah.
You don't think about it all?
I do think about it.
Um,
the,
the main thing is make sure that before I'm retired and my kids are set for life
with their universities or at their houses,
all that stuff,
that's the number one goal.
Then when I retire,
I don't know.
I got a lot of options I could do,
you know,
I'm going to see which one I'm gonna light the most,
cause whatever I'm going to do.
Obviously nothing I love as much as fighting.
Nothing will make me wake up at six in the morning to go fucking run.
No nothing.
Don't have that love.
And me,
when you asked about the longevity is just cause I love it so much.
I don't have to work for it.
I just,
I love it.
I love what I do.
Even hitting the bag for 35,
40 minutes sometimes it's so fucking boring and monotonous.
But if I've got the right music going on,
I mean a little bit of water,
let's do it.
You know,
I'm gonna have fun doing it,
you know?
So,
uh,
I got to just find something that my heart is solely in and I'm having fun.
I still haven't figured out what that is.
You know,
maybe skiing,
you know,
every time I go skiing,
the skews are trying to recruit me.
They're like,
Yo,
who is this guy?
Man,
we need this guy over here in our team to,
it may maybe scheme and that she gets my blood pumping.
Really?
You like ski.
It's fucking love it man.
I hate it.
I love that.
She was worried about falling.
So that's your problem.
That isn't my problem.
Fucking snowman.
I was going to happen.
You've been kicked in the head forever.
Had their fucking ACL torn apart.
I've already had two knee reconstructions,
so when I go down the hill I'm like don't get hurt.
Don't get hurt.
Didn't get hurt.
That's so crazy.
I'm brain thing cause I'm thinking there's no way I can get her when I'm on
those names.
I'm just fucking going
as fast as I can tell you one of those guys.
Yeah.
Like there's no way I could get hurt.
It's fucking snow.
Wow.
You definitely get hurt.
Yeah,
definitely.
Fucking know.
While I was standing still like pass my friends.
Hey guys,
slow down to to say what's up and just like some seven year old men dean and see
that I'm stopping up moving here and just fucking loud plowed it mean to the
kneecaps.
Good thing.
There's so more flexible.
Nothing torn.
Nothing.
But it was like a good hit though.
You don't like a good little low kick out of nowhere.
You know,
I worry about that with my kids some clodhopper Paul.
But if they,
if they start young though to forget about it.
Oh no,
they're good.
They're already doing black diamond.
So fuckers.
Yeah,
but they,
they,
they're so low to the ground.
They're tiny little skis and shut the no fear at that age.
Once they already funding and once or twice like,
Oh dad,
it's just snow.
I watch some of those fucking men going down those hills though.
Oh,
shush.
When they like when they drop them off in the helicopter.
Oh,
that's ridiculous.
I watched a video the other night of,
uh,
a guy went down this mountain that no one's ever skied down before.
They dropped him off at the top and he had to climb the first couple of feet
down with the skis on before he got to this open shoot.
I was like,
what in the fuck are you doing?
He's climbing like you can't just ski.
There's rocks everywhere and shit.
That's great.
Fuck you.
Blows my mind.
Yeah,
go get a better hobby is ridiculous.
Sliding down a mountain.
I might end up in there one day.
None that not no time soon cause those guys are a lifetime of skill but I
wouldn't,
I wouldn't take it off.
You know like I'd love to ski one of those crazy mountains that are just fucking
super duper steep and just rip it.
You know one thing about skiing is you could do it when you're old.
Yeah.
Cause this lady who was teaching my daughter,
she was giving my daughter lessons at the ski place.
She was like deep into her sixties and she's skiing great.
Was they got technique technique.
You know they probably grew up in the snow.
I started skiing when I was like 30 you know,
so I got a lot of catching up to do.
Yeah,
it's a,
I just don't to Ari,
my friend Ari,
he broke his wrist last year and he broke his ankle two years ago.
He's always fucking himself up.
He's that guy.
Balls to the wall.
I don't know.
He probably is on mushrooms when it does.
That's a good time to ski,
man.
Fucking that's a best time.
That's why I know a couple people that have done it on mushrooms.
They say you ski.
Really?
Yeah.
You like it.
Oh,
what's the best thing about skiing that mushrooms?
Well,
it could go both ways because it fucks up your depth perception.
You know,
like,
I don't know where the trees are.
So the,
the first time I did it I was like super grandma.
You know,
like everybody's like,
what's wrong with him?
Like,
no,
no.
Just leave me the fuck alone because the snow is all the same too.
Right.
So now it just fluctuate you depth perception so bad.
You could see the divots in the snow and
everything gets pixelated.
And you are really tripping hard then.
Oh man,
everything is the same and I can't really see the bumps and then I don't see the
bumps.
I just feed them and at Whoa,
Whoa,
all right,
I'm going to need to tough this one out and let's do it,
you know?
And then the next time I did it,
the ladder literal.
Less of a dosage had a blast,
you know?
Yeah.
They say it's a,
it's a micro dose thing.
Yes.
It's like don't take like three grams.
Take like a half a gram.
Yeah,
something like that.
Well the first time I was a Zune,
the bro Science and it was like,
Oh yeah,
I think it's like for grabs is cool man,
let's go on a fat and like a slight fast,
you know,
he's the problem with that,
the vision thing when things,
when you do the mushrooms and things get pixelated where you see like almost
like a matrix around you that yeah,
I would imagine that that would fuck you up skin.
You wouldn't be able to see all the creases in the snow and shit.
And then you just feel it all of a sudden,
you know what the fuck out.
You have a snowboard.
I did it for like half a day.
I was pretty cool.
But I uh,
I used to ski like inline,
like in parks,
you know,
like on ramps on halfpipes.
Rollerblade yeah.
So I could like jump on rails and halfpipes and uh,
I could even do like a front flip on,
on my skates.
But this was,
and I was like 13,
14.
Yeah.
So skiing came very easy to meet and snowboarding that so much.
Cause I didn't skateboard when I was a kid.
I skateboarded as a kid,
but I've never snowboarded but uh,
the people that do it,
they say it's easier to get better at snowboarding than it is to get better at
skiing.
I said it's like,
it's hard in the beginning,
but once you get it,
it's easy to get better at.
Oh,
okay.
But when you fall a lot,
a lot of dudes fall this,
the snowboard goes up in the air.
You're feet are stuck on it and he landed right on your fucking head.
A lot of people get knocked the fuck out because you can't move your legs
individually like you can if your skin and you land on the tailbone a lot to a
lot of people telling me.
Yeah.
And if you're skiing and you land funky,
the ski snap loose and you can move your legs around.
Board is shot.
Yeah.
He's trapped in a snowboard.
Is this shit too that people go through to the trees like fucking silver shirt
for?
That's fun man.
Yeah,
but that's not rush.
This low one down part with those seems different.
Like less options to slow down.
Oh,
I love all that shit.
Anything he gets my heart pumping.
Right.
Do a skydive or anything crazy like that.
I haven't done the skydiving because I'm afraid of the law.
I've heard bad stories about the lighting,
how you are with the skiing.
He got a couple buddies.
He gotten hurt.
I got a couple of buddies had gotten hurt on the landing of skydiving.
I'm like,
I can't do that.
I'm fighting.
So fighting.
Whoo.
Yeah.
Have you had any knee problems?
Numerous knee problems.
I've turned them in this case or a couple times on both knees.
From wrestling practice hall.
From wrestling practice.
Sure.
Yeah.
Do you,
did you get him scoped or what'd you do about it and then just rehab.
I got a big fear of going to sleep by uh,
anesthesia.
Yeah.
Really?
Got To love supreme fear that I don't want that in my life right now.
I'm not ready for that.
That's a sucky way to die.
Go to sleep to get your knee fixed.
And that's a wrap.
See in heaven,
tweet.
Tweet.
Yeah.
Not yet.
Not so you just basically whatever meniscus tears you value.
You just dealt with that.
Just Rehab.
And then I also heard from doctors,
you don't really need them in this cause is just going to fucking hurt.
Like fuck.
So you don't really need meniscus.
That's what they told me like a lot
of times instead of scoping it,
they cut it.
You know,
like I know that athletes,
you just cut it,
you know,
it got pieces of it.
Yeah.
Especially depending on illiquid paid.
It's a bucket handled tear or how bad the tear is.
Yeah.
Nice.
Uh,
Mike Brown has annoy his meniscus cut and he was the one who was sending me last
time I fucked up my meniscus.
He said do not get a scope because then you're going to reinjury and you're
going to be again through the whole thing.
Get it snipped out,
getting caught,
you know,
and just,
he just got it cut out all of it.
Yeah.
Joe Ramiro,
same thing.
I don't think Joel Irma has a meniscus.
Sure.
Yeah.
Cause I have,
I've had numerous problems with my meniscus and I was about to go in and get the
surgery and I was asking,
everybody's had the same problem and I was like,
fuck it,
I'm just going to rehab it out.
Just do rehab.
And I did Rehab for like four,
five months and it got better.
Oh Wow.
Four or five months,
Huh?
Well that was our last year in 2018 that's what of did to a larger part of the
year.
Just he loved injuries that I had,
you know,
just get better and better and better.
So when you say like Rehab at what,
what kind of rehab are you doing for your meniscus?
We'll be doing like where they,
you go to the place and the guy tells you like you're holding the towel.
Things like this.
Okay.
Different than the foam mat.
Yeah,
physical therapy,
you know,
that's what I did.
And what are the,
what is it,
what's your diet like?
Ah Man,
I got many of diets.
Like when you're in training,
when you're trading that when you,
when you're not,
when you knock out there until,
I'm sure you ate like a wild animal fat.
I got many of diets at all times.
So I just Kinda,
I 55 I used to have to die so hard.
Eight to 10 weeks I would have to die to bring my body to like one 73 one 74
especially the last three,
four years of my career mixed with a lot of running.
You know,
at 70 I don't have to do that.
So I'm still kind of strict.
I just stopped eating after like a certain time,
like 7:00 PM I shop eating,
you know,
wake up nine last training session.
Uh,
it depends.
It could be sometimes I got,
I'll finish at around 10,
10 39 nudges drink.
Yeah.
I'll just don't need anything after you train.
No,
I just drink a shit ton of water.
You know,
this one I'm like,
I'm training training that I'm used to it,
you know,
cause I,
you should do it at 55.
She couldn't gain weight.
So I just,
let's say I went for a run at like 10 o'clock at night,
finished at 12.
I just get back,
drink a shit ton of water,
wake up and then have my meal.
You know,
I don't eat when I'm in training camp.
One thing that I notice,
um,
I don't like to,
uh,
have a big breakfast before I go train.
It fucks me up,
really slows me down.
Nobody's processing all that shit.
I just don't feel as accurate.
I could just wake up and go to the gym and do fine.
If I wake up,
eat till all that stuff,
then go to a gym.
It's not the same,
you know?
Lazy.
Yeah.
Gee.
It takes your body to digest it.
That's legit.
Yeah.
I always feel the same way.
I think you're better off.
Just eat a little bit of fruit.
Yeah,
a little bit of pineapple.
Anything with sugar,
some coughing goals,
light.
I don't want my,
my system actually didn't having to dissolve things as I'm already drained.
That's why I'm surprised that you're running late at night and then you're not
eating something and then you go on through the entire night with no food and
then a light breakfast and I'll burn right through it.
Like I'm,
I'm burning through fat in my seat.
Do you have a nutritionist that you consult or do you have numerous ones that
add 155 I had numerous ones and I took what each one gave me that was like,
wow,
this actually helped me for this or for this and I've jot those down on my book
and I use those things still to this day to some things that I use and then
mixing what with the stuff that I know works for me.
You know,
like I know for a fact somebody,
numerous nutrition told me no,
but that's wrong.
You should just wake up at six in the morning,
get a me on an eight in the morning,
get another meal,
and then by 10 o'clock you're good to go.
Not Buddy,
I'm just going to go to the gym and I'm going to fucking feel amazing.
I don't need all those extra fucking meals.
And then after that I pig out and when I eat I like,
it's almost a religious experience for me.
I like to be very happy.
So if we go to a place to eat and I've never been in,
you're telling me this is the place right here,
this is,
where were you want to eat at?
I'm getting everything on the fucking menu.
It looks,
I'll feel this fucking table up and I'm going to try everything and I'm going to
know what's good at this place.
I don't like to put restrictions when I eat,
but I'll eat like that all day long,
you know?
So my one or two meals that I eat,
they're powerful,
you know,
so you real light,
but when you eat a big meal,
you just go hog and then nothing,
nothing after 7:00 PM at night.
Yeah.
None after 7:00 PM basically like intermittent fasting.
Really some naval mimicking that.
And then I,
I saw that the innovating fashion,
it started breaking down like the details of it,
you know,
because where I got it from is that,
uh,
when I was at 55,
let's sad finish my workout at American top team.
I finished at 178 pounds.
Fuck three weeks ago.
Okay.
I get back home,
I'd eat it a little sump cause I just finished on a two hour workout and I'll
put my sweats on and go run and I got to run 10 11 o'clock at night and everyone
for like an hour I'd get back.
I'd touched down like to one 72 maybe one 74 I couldn't eat.
I just drink water.
So I got used to that,
that regimen of not eating after my workouts,
you know,
I'm feeling fine.
The next stage is a shit ton of water.
Your body just got used to it.
Yeah.
Maybe electrolytes or whatever.
And then when those,
the,
the intermittent fasting diet or the,
or the fast thing came up and they put the science behind it,
I'm like,
oh no wonder it makes sense to me.
You know,
it's not that I'm a special Mulan is,
there's a science behind this,
you know?
Yeah.
It's actually healthy for your body needs.
Brakes.
Yeah.
Now when you're doing strength and conditioning and things on those lines,
how often are you doing that?
A week?
Um,
it depends where,
what stage I'm at in the fight.
If I'm like three weeks out obviously or like 12 weeks out,
like right now I'll lift weights,
running,
swimming,
anything.
We just get my heart going and I do a lot of kettle bells.
I liked that it's a,
it's like a full body work out and it's kind of like almost rustling,
you know,
when you're,
when you're getting in there and the reps and it's heavy.
If your techniques off,
he just fucked up that rep,
you're wasting too much energy.
You're not going to get to those projections you want to get.
And I got lucky down at the gym that I trained,
uh,
one of the Kettlebell champion.
She's a world champion,
he's at the gym,
so he's showing me like a lot of technique and a lot of the,
the grit behind it.
And it's amazing.
I mean,
this guy doesn't incredible things,
you know,
so it's uh,
it's huge for me to kettlebells I liked him,
you know,
my,
a lot of strength and conditioning too with my coach.
Ah,
he sues guy.
We've been together for like 12 years,
you know.
Yeah.
I'm a big fan of kettlebells as well.
It's my favorite exercise tool.
If I'd pick one thing that I would say,
give me a chin up bar and kettlebells and I'm good,
a grip back.
And then the sheer coordination,
pop them up in the air,
making the whole body work as one whole unit
when you're tired and you can,
you can't fucking not concentrate because every one of those techniques,
every one of those,
those lives has a severe technique behind the,
and if you fuck up man,
fuck up your back,
your shoulder,
you just throw your whole shit off.
Yeah,
yeah.
Now,
um,
what,
what do you alter when you get closer to a fight?
Like what do you eliminate?
Do you eliminate the weightlifting?
Do you
the,
the length of the training session,
you know,
as in when we're more out from the firewall train for longer periods to three
hours,
you know,
three hours,
always the Max and maybe I'll do that twice in a day.
You know,
when I'm closer to the fight,
may be an hour and a half tops,
tops,
two hours and maybe two of those in a day,
you know,
and then that's it.
You know,
Marshall 34.
So I don't like,
uh,
not when I was like 26 that I could fucking train 10 hours in one day and wake
up the next day like nothing happened,
you know?
So now I just,
I,
I also listen to my body like,
man,
that last session beat me up.
I'm going to do on one hour session now,
you know.
Do you take your heart rate?
Do you use heart rate variability monitors or anything like that?
No,
nothing that I didn't even know what she's just said.
Old School,
you know,
people are doing that to see what their heart rate is when they wake up.
And I'll see if,
uh,
like if your heart rate's inconsistent,
say if you have a resting heart rate of a,
you know,
40 beats per minute,
then you wake up one day,
it's 47 48 that might indicate that you're overtrained 52 53 would be a real
good indication and you would probably want to either do active recovery that
day or just take the day off,
maybe even go for a light hike or something like that.
And my mission investments and stuff.
There's a lot of thought behind that because sometimes people are getting sick
and they don't realize it.
That just too tough and they just push through it.
I feel flat today.
But what's really going on is your body is fighting something off.
Yeah,
it makes perfect sense.
Yeah.
How much sleep you're making.
Sure you get a night
for the larger part of my career because um,
I have a sleeping problems.
It really bad.
I would seem like four or five hours and be fucking perfect man.
Yeah,
be perfect.
Never,
never have a problem.
You know,
as it started getting to know them and trying to force myself to see,
that's one big thing when my coaches and my management,
cause they know I sleep in a like on fight week,
I'd be up in the lobby 30 in the morning and then you go to seep,
wake up at eight in the morning and no,
we've got to change this,
you know.
So I've been trying to change that ally and I just try to put myself in bed
early and then I just stay in the United.
Do Nothing.
The phone's already off.
There's no TV in my room.
I'm just chiming in.
But this isn't a fight camp.
This is not like year round.
You know?
And I'm just trying to go to seat,
you know,
however long takes,
does
American top team have a float float tank?
No,
not yet.
But then did you just hear Joe Rogan?
They need to fucking float broke.
Get the float man.
I think they did.
What are they thinking about it at one point in time?
Was that what was going on the shore and now Dan,
get the fucking float.
Jan needs to float.
You know we love you Dan.
Get that fucking tank in there baby.
I'll hook you up.
I'll get you to the right people.
Float lab from Jonah float lab advantage.
Shout out to the float lab.
Yeah,
the guy put my tank in here.
They're the best tank.
Smell.
Show it to you afterwards.
The there are so ridiculously over engineered.
But when you get in the man,
you relax like it changes your world sings.
You're fucking awesome.
I've done it like a two or three times your fucking mind.
But is there a good spot near you?
No.
Near me.
Remember like on the road,
two hours up north that socks?
Yeah.
Dan should open up a spot down there.
I mean it's,
it'd be great for fighters as long as you keep them from jacking off in there.
That's a problem.
You get a little too relaxed.
Certain guys that are already flagging now so and so can come in as Roger Smith
got evacuated.
My brother,
you got to have a passport for these waters are,
yeah.
There's certain dudes that are just freaks.
You gotta be careful with them.
Athletic freaks ain't fucking freak.
Freak's double freaks.
Yeah.
Well you,
well you guys have,
how many people at your gym?
Me,
Bobby at one of the freakiest Jim's ever.
In terms of talent,
overall talent,
how family fighters there?
I Dunno man.
Sometimes I get to the pro classes and there's like 50 pro fighters,
you know,
raising 40 pro fighters in the map because the main Matt and the other main
matter covered in the cages cover.
Then the square cage where I'm always trained in it,
which fits like another 10 people.
It's completely covered with with pro athletes,
you know,
and that that we have,
we have the 11 o'clock to like 1245 session and then different session for like
either the lighter or the bigger guys will come in at a different session,
you know?
And then we've got guys throughout the day doing their individuals rainy.
So
it's just crazy how much your time is spent doing group classes versus how much
of it is time.
It's individual specialized stuff like say working on something,
a combination of land on till or you know what you're planning for ass grin
group classes will be more like a,
well I won't really learn.
It's not that I can't learn too much,
but I'm not like my Mike Brown for example,
which,
which is the guy that runs my camp loving and Thompson,
Gosh Frey guy.
Not only is he a great guy,
but his brain is,
he's the like Elon Musk of like fighting and shit man is his ideas are fucking
dope solid and like way ahead of their time always.
You know a lot of stuff that we're seeing now.
Mike Brown has been preaching to us for like a while,
so he knows me pretty well.
He knows man,
mass general can only do about two moves a day.
So if he's going to show me something,
he showed me one to two moves tops and I just,
I'm a driller.
I'll just drill those moves as many times as it takes me for me to get them in
that,
that's like my group,
you know,
that's like,
okay go just drill this and he knows that I need at least an hour of drilling
with a brand new move for me to get it,
you know?
And then after that just go live with whoever's in the class,
you know,
whoever they they brought for me.
Now what,
when you say you,
you drill a lot.
Like are you drilling a lot striking drills,
MMA drills,
mark where wrestling drills basically everything.
You just constantly driller.
I drill,
I drew a ton and I go live button.
But I like to compliment it with a lot of driven and I just feel that I'm always
on my best game when a drill and that sometimes I take away from drilling
complete because I feel drilled down.
Like,
man,
I've been journey so much,
just want to go live now.
You know?
But,
um,
usually every day that I'm in a gym,
I'm drilling a particular technique.
You know?
I think that's so important.
Oh,
super important for every,
every up,
martial arts,
Jujitsu,
anything more.
Sure.
Large drill or you know,
you're draining your free throws or,
or whatever it is.
You have to just drill it to your body,
knows how to do it without thinking about it.
Yeah.
That's why when you see guys that just spar too much and all they want to do a
spar,
like,
man,
you know,
cure.
You're,
you're,
you're decreasing your chances of success and to think you're,
you're enjoying because you're just not spending enough time focusing on the
fundamentals and techniques kind of sharpens who keep those tools,
you know,
like keep moving him around like you keep adding to them.
Of course.
Driving Guy's fucking nuts when you just drill and eventually you hit that 1000
mark.
It's not the same when you were doing it five or six times,
you know?
I'm not giving her too much wisdom though.
He's,
people are going to know what's up,
but that's really is true straining.
It's boring so people don't enjoy it as much.
It's not like I'm the only sociopath and then you could ask him.
I enjoy drilling,
you know,
had a good pace,
good speed where we're just going in.
It's almost like a live warm,
just drilling that move when I'm giving all my energy into it.
I love it man.
Well you also wear that.
That's going to bring you success.
Yeah.
Oh,
of course.
But I just,
I just love it.
You know,
the sheer making sure that my penetration steppers right.
Or my left hand was up when I throw my right hand and my coach goes,
hey,
good job.
Do it again.
Okay Pam.
That I fucking love it man.
Now you,
when you have a fight coming up,
like say with aspirin,
are you watching footage on him?
I don't watch footage.
My uh,
Mike Brown,
Bollinger none.
This guy,
although the watch footage on and tell me what to do,
what not to do,
you know,
like for the tow fight,
same thing,
you know,
or maybe they'll send me like a clip that they wanted to see me like when a
Woodley FOBT till they're like,
look how Woodley a,
counter them with this on or look what till did there,
there's so many like little clips in,
I'll watch him.
But to watch fights,
nine any watch like my opponents fight.
Now what about recovery?
You guys,
uh,
did the get a lot of massage?
Do you do ice baths to any shit like that?
I do.
Uh,
I,
I've always done ice baths.
She in there throughout my career,
but thanks to man,
my good friend Michael Miller,
I tried to do a lot more,
which I still need to do more.
You know,
a good two,
three times a week is when I feel like at my best sauna I use you for recovery,
you know,
especially after like a lot of the guests that you've had in your show.
I've always done the Sanada to cut weight and knew that it had great benefits
and training in the sauna,
but it didn't know the science behind them.
Then you have like odd doctor Ron,
they'll go,
Patrick will come in and it's like mind blowing.
Yeah.
This all makes sense.
Why the Saunas so amazing.
Why I feel great after I use a Sana,
maybe not immediately because I have the two hour wrestling practice or striking
practices and then you go in the sauna cause you're like heavy.
They want you to work out in that you feel like shit afterwards.
Yeah.
But surprisingly the next day I don't feel that bad or that they have to and I
just thought nothing of it,
you know,
just fucking whatever man.
It's just,
I feel good today.
I had a great breakfast I guess,
but I started thinking about times that I was implementing the Sauna law in my
training regimen to times I wasn't.
And I was like,
wow,
the sauna things amazing for everything,
you know?
Yeah,
no,
it's huge.
It says giant for reduction of inflammation.
And there was that study that they did and was it Norway or Sweden or somewhere
where they said there's a 40% decrease in mortality amongst all causes,
stroke,
heart attack,
cancer,
everything for people that,
yeah,
40% decrease in mortality for people that use the sauna.
I think it was four times a week for 20 minutes at a time at 180 degrees.
I think that was the study that they ran and they just showed an 80 degrees.
So they just,
they,
which is,
you know,
normal temperature anywhere between one 70 and 190 [inaudible] where a lot of
people have their,
a sauna set.
Uh,
but they said that in that hot range for 20 minutes,
your body produces so many heat shock proteins that it just helps with so many
different health problems.
Yeah.
When I heard,
uh,
Ms. Patrick go sales things,
my fucking mind blew up.
Yeah.
It's crazy,
right?
I'll never have to take pharmaceutical drugs.
Nobody's ever going to take tell me you need these pillars.
Right.
And then people that hear this,
do they doubted,
you know,
they have one profile attorney,
Joe Rogan tenny and they had a doctor telling you,
you want to cure problems.
Just coin the sauna.
Yeah,
man.
People with arthritis,
you know,
another thing that's great is cryotherapy.
Cryotherapy is great for people with,
uh,
inflammation issues to anything where you can get your body freaking out about
temperature.
Your body freaks out about temperature,
whether it's cold or hot and heat.
Your body produces cold shock or heat shock proteins.
And then that really helps your body reduce inflammation.
That's fucking insane.
He just feel better too,
right?
You get how they like,
ah,
I just feel better even when I'd be sucked down like Manafort fucking shit.
I just lost fucking four or five pounds of water after a practice in the Sani
feel like shit.
But then I'd take a bath and then go to sleep,
wake up the next day feeling good.
You know,
I put the water back in the system obviously,
but I would just feel good and I didn't quite know why this is happening.
You know,
like let's say I got kicked in my elbow,
my elbow would blow up and then for some reason that day I had fucking 45
minutes of in the sauna cause that's what my coaches thought I needed.
The sweating would dramatically go down,
but I wouldn't attribute to that just to be like,
oh shit,
that's crazy fucking wolverine.
You know,
marine had something to do with it,
but at the sauna had something to do with it too.
Now,
um,
you,
as you getting,
you know,
you're one of the top contenders in the division now and as things kind of heat
up,
are you having to do more media obligations before your big fights now?
No.
That's just fucking say no to you,
man.
I'm fucking only what if you get a fight for the title?
They would probably gonna make you do all that shit,
won't they?
You,
you want this circus show?
This is how it comes,
buddy.
You know,
cause I,
I can't watch,
am I gonna fucking flight air lay flat in New York.
Fly here.
Racks.
You're right.
I won't pay it now.
Don't get me wrong.
I'm a fucking soldier for the money.
You're going to pay me for these fucking numerous TV outlet stores.
You got me going to him selling products.
I'll do it,
man.
You know,
and I don't want to sound like I'm at a company man,
but I'd like to get paid for my services.
If I got to be talking to numerous people,
that's not what I signed up for.
I signed up to punch people in the face.
Let's get that right.
And if I got a green speeches out,
giving out my secrets of wisdom,
pay me some money for that core.
I'll do whatever you want them.
Yeah,
well it definitely takes away from me too.
He's done so much energy.
You have and this definitely takes away.
Yeah,
definitely takes away.
And I feel also like,
like the guys that are constantly putting stuff out there,
right?
Shit,
man,
people get bored.
He'd be fucking just putting shit out there.
You know?
And certain people are putting certain things out there,
they fucking,
they gravitate to the things.
This guy's not on a lot of talk shows or whatever.
I want to hear what he had.
The sand,
this particular,
if you're constantly like this goes international and this gives an answer,
they,
everybody,
the notification comes in,
they're already fucking put you on mute.
You know,
and you did that to yourself.
You got nobody to blame but yourself,
your little Instagram whore and I'm not talking about to the ladies.
I would never talk to a lady like that.
I'm talking about to the dudes that are fucking straight sluts to my ladies.
I love you long time Niladri
when you have been in the game,
as long as you have and have been as successful as you have,
you have information that is very valuable to young fighters.
They can learn shit from you without having to experience a lot of the negative
things that you've experienced a lot without having some of the mistakes that
you've made.
You know,
some of the things you learned that were positive,
you could teach people and,
but oftentimes as fighters get older then retire,
that all that knowledge just goes away.
It just gets lost because the fighters either don't become a coach or don't ever
write it down or don't do interviews.
I think a guy like you in particular,
because you're a very crafty fighter,
you have a lot of valuable information for young people,
for young guys coming up.
Oh I do.
I know it.
You know,
and you know how I got that information,
putting myself in uncomfortable spots.
You know,
I went to the University of Wyoming,
which I loved that experience.
It's higher than Colorado.
And I'm with the [inaudible] national program ran by Mark Branch.
Um,
I mean David Branch was r and Chris Pendleton and these guys are fucking studs
and they'd let me come in there and just some me fucking
fighter man,
you know,
and they let me come in there,
stay with them for about a month and just Russell and be a part of the program.
So I learned what worked at the high level or not,
because I might think when you get a single leg,
I could back to the battery,
I might think.
And I go over here to this university,
I'm going to find that if it works in up and there's a saint,
Dan went to the state,
uh,
University of Oregon got to wrestle over there.
Um,
I've done a lot of high level boxing camp,
put good boxes,
just being around them.
Amateur will,
champion's gold medalist,
you know,
in Miami,
we're a hub for the Cuban crime wave of great boxers.
You know what I mean?
All these guys that are Olympians,
they come in there and,
and I'd be at the gym with them picking their brain,
get beat up by them learning since I was young.
So I,
I,
for the boxing fundamentals,
I got very,
very lucky.
I didn't even know what I had at to me at that access was that I'd be working
out with gold medalists,
world champions.
It was insane.
You know,
should I sing one thing?
I would tell any young fight,
if you want to learn something,
submerge any,
you know,
if you,
if I want to learn Jujitsu,
I'm not going to go to rex Quando.
I'm going to fucking go find the dopest Jujitsu guy and get humbled.
You know,
a lot of people don't like to get home.
I don't want to go with that guys.
You would good at wrestling.
No Man,
shut the fuck up.
Put the ego aside and go get humbled.
Learn because the more time you put into that craft,
eventually whatever's bad,
we'll get good if you put the time into it.
You know?
And a lot of people don't like to do that.
And I think even more nowadays that I see on the mat now with the eagles and the
social media and like people filming and Shit,
there's a lot of profiles that I see sitting out.
The don't want to do the rest in class because a couple of wrestling suds just
walked in through the door.
So there's like two types of guys that when I see these all American and
national champions,
I'm like,
Whoa,
and he's going to be a good practice.
These guys are my weight.
I better be on my a game.
Um,
put some good music on.
This shit's going to get crazy.
Or there's the guys that when they walk in,
they're like,
Eh,
I don't need it.
You know?
Anyways,
I'm the fight in the restaurant and the,
I'm always hyped for the challenge,
you know,
to push myself to the fucking sheer limit and see what comes out of that.
You know?
So you think a lot of it is just a mentality to embrace,
struggle and embrace difficult moments and,
and embrace the opportunity to learn and grow.
Yes.
And unfortunately in this sport,
you don't have to get a concussion because in boxing you don't,
don't take me wrong,
you don't have to spa hard to be a good striker,
you don't.
But there's certain things like wrestling,
you gotta wrestle hard.
You got to draw hard Jujitsu.
Same thing.
You got to draw her,
you got to get you going with Marcello Garcia,
you're going to get fucking tapped a bunch of times.
Guess what buddy?
Who Cares?
Well learned that humbling experience,
joy that you know,
if you get a chance to roll with a guy like that,
take full advantage of it.
And nowadays it seems like,
uh,
a lot of sometimes futile want to do that.
You know,
like I'm in the mix alarm in one of the biggest gyms and I see sometimes guys
don't want to take those challenges in,
you know,
like a top notch MMA fighter.
Go straight wrestling with some college rest or some high school kids.
It's just a stud at Russell.
You do that.
Put yourself in that uncomfortable position.
See what happens bro.
You know.
Do you think you'll ever be a coach?
I could
be.
You know,
I got a couple images and a guy got my boy Charlie decker.
That's that day.
He's also like a friend in the amateur and uh,
he's uh,
he's doing good things in amateur night.
He's going to go approach gonna fucking,
he's going to tear it up,
man.
One day I,
hopefully he'll be in your show.
Me Get an interview,
guys.
Got a lot of tonic.
But um,
I dunno.
I Dunno if I'll be a coach.
It's a full time job.
It's a full time job and you gotta be committed to somebody.
Right.
And if they don't have the same mentality that you had,
you're going to get frustrated and I am.
Sometimes fighters don't like to pay me.
What are you going to do now?
You've got to collect from a fighter.
She's going to get crazy man.
Don't like to pay.
I don't even like to paint.
And you know something about me,
Joe.
I like money,
man.
If I work I better get paid man.
Cause if I don't get paid,
it's going to be a fucking problem and it's going to be a fucking problem.
But there's a lot of fighters that do pain that are,
I'm fucking amazing in that are the most straight edge.
Do you know?
Yeah.
I mean certainly a guy like you,
if you ever did decide to be a coach you would have a lot of choices.
Yeah.
But what I'm getting at is that the very least you should write some of that
shit down.
Like what's written down.
Yeah,
we got the the street survival series coming out.
Volume one,
two and three is going to jump very soon.
Books,
DVDs,
everything.
Everything's coming out here,
man.
You should know when it's coming out.
But it's coming out soon though.
You should write a book about your experience or was it just,
just go on from the backyard fights that people could see on the Internet with
Kimball to where you are today?
It's pretty fucking incredible.
It's amazing.
That's what an incredible rise to the top.
Yeah.
And you know what?
Somebody could tell all the young fighters before anybody saw this before
anybody telling me and youtube or anything,
I sighed up here.
I invested in myself,
I believed in myself and that's why I put myself in these tough situations that
go with the best wrestler in the workout room,
the best striker from the world,
and just constantly get there.
Cause I knew the difference between me and them was only time I just had to put
in time.
Where'd you,
where'd you get,
where'd I get it?
Maybe God opened up my mind and just gave me the messages.
Just growing up,
very humble and just fucking wanting certain things that I didn't have and just
like,
I'm going to,
I'm going to get this.
But understanding that really just takes work.
She's really,
really understanding.
It really just takes work and it really takes work and it really takes the right
mindset.
You're not just the work itself,
but the way you're embracing difficult challenges instead of shying away from
them and to protect your ego,
you're doing the opposite.
Gotcha.
Why so?
Only way I'm in combat sports in combat sports,
tennis,
maybe there's another way.
I'm not coaching tennis,
but as long as combat sports is,
you're not being set up,
but someone's going to fucking murder when you're first starting out.
Exactly.
Striking.
That's not what you want.
You don't want to get,
yeah.
You know,
I've got 10 pro fights your first day here and I break your nose.
That doesn't do anything.
But it's just embracing those challenges,
whether it be running a mile in six minutes or drilling for twice as long just
to techniques because you're kind of dumb and you fucking got to just do it over
and over and over and
over embracing,
you know?
Well,
I'm glad you're going to put some of this information out.
And I think,
um,
this is something that,
as I was saying,
like a guy like you that's been in the game for a long,
long time and you've learned a lot about what it takes to become a world class
fighter,
that that information a lot of times just goes away when that fire retires.
So many fighters have retired and you don't really know too much about the
process or what they learned.
Well,
and uh,
we got a document,
he's been filming for about three years,
but we've had trouble when the UFC sold it to like EHP and getting all the
rights and in and things that'll go associated with dropping documented like
that.
And then that documentary,
I told him from the star wars when we were going to do it,
if we're going to do it,
I want it done right and meaning I want a lot of control over it.
And I,
I want a lot of training.
You know,
I want a lot of the things that are doing training to get me in shape.
Some people find it cool,
some people won't.
So in that documentary,
there's a lot of just high,
straight a train,
you know,
like a lot of the Cuban mythology that goes behind it from my,
from my coaches that are Cuban wa what we like to do to prepare for the fight,
how we break it down,
different shit.
And then people normally say,
uh,
in the preparation.
Yeah.
Actually you,
you know Joelle well,
sure.
And uh,
and stuff.
Joelle,
my,
my coach,
which she's a trained yard as well.
And in and out of the Cuban community,
they have a big,
uh,
especially if they grew up in Cuba,
they have that big conspiracy theory.
Like nobody else.
They,
whenever I'm hitting pads or anything like that,
I'm about to fight somebody.
You will never see me do a technique on the pads that I will do in the fight.
I shouldn't even say this because Michael was just going to slap me in the face.
You will never see me do anything.
It might resemble anything had to do in the fight.
And he lives by that,
you know,
he doesn't ease another guy that just shies away from cameras,
hates cameras.
He's always in my corner.
He's got a yellow Bandana or something yelling and he's been in my corner.
Joel's going to numerous,
numerous guys corner and um,
they're very like secretive of the training,
you know,
they think that everybody's watching.
We still,
you know,
they think America might invade Cuba still so that I know.
Who knows.
Right.
So the training footage,
I don't want that leaking out,
you know.
And uh,
I've most of my career been late day number for the document and we opened up a
lot of things that I,
that we do for training for like from reflexes to ways to recover how we spar
high set up the spine,
things like that.
You know,
what kind of shit that you do this unusual?
Uh,
not unusual I guess I would say,
but I dunno,
I could,
we could do like two hours of boxing ray,
just straight boxing and we would just break down fundamentals.
I would just,
just tooth two hours straight basics,
which is fucking boring.
But it's just like endurance mixed with the technique.
You know,
we do also a lot of,
uh,
right from here,
from this chair will punch from here,
hit the patch from here,
from the chair,
just
horrid orange with the pads.
With the gloves.
Hmm.
Skol five minute rounds without using your legs.
What?
Using the lakes.
You try it out and you told me how that fusion,
it's fucking great,
you know?
And like right now for that,
I'm going to get kicked in the fucking leg pretty hard.
And now he's really wanting to tell you.
When I tell you this man is secretive,
how's he going to feel about the documentary?
He doesn't know how much he's getting into doctrine because he's very like,
this is for us.
You know,
why would you release is why you're still fighting with dcis when you're done
fighting type guy,
you know?
And why do you want to release it?
Why are you still fighting?
I mean fucking,
you can't stop the Sun from rising,
you know,
going to stop me if you know my techniques,
it's not going to change anything.
What's coming.
It's coming.
You know,
that's a beautiful way to look at it.
Well listen brother,
I'm glad we got together and did this,
man.
I appreciate you as a fighter.
You're,
you're an interesting cat and uh,
I wish you nothing but the bass and I'm,
I'm very excited to see that fight.
I just write,
try to reach.
All right.
Um,
uh,
game bread.
What,
what is it and gain bread MMA.
What is your bread fighter game bred fighter.
And if you want one of these little three patient or sodas,
shirts,
everybody
fucking shirt after it made the shirt out.
I gotta get paid cause fighting.
Those are high,
but it doesn't really pay us how we should,
you know,
so,
uh,
what did we get that shirt?
Three pizza and a soda.
Hold on,
we'll figure this out.
I actually know where to get these gain bred fighter on Instagram.
Game bred fighter on Twitter.
Same thing,
right?
Yes.
Shirt and game bread or official.com.
Gain bread at your shop.
But it comes at the end of this week.
The website's fully running and stuff.
You get all the shirts you want,
get yourself a three piece in the soul of the ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you,
brother.
That was awesome.
Yes,
sir.